THIS- JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OF THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
THE SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO IS THAT RIGHT NUMBER
TWO NUMBER TWO- EASTERN ARE OR
CELL PHONE. OUR STATIONS SO UP
FOR MINE OFF RIGHT NOW. AND SO
WE CAN HEAR A MRS IN- THIS IS
THE THIRD- DEPARTMENT MOTOR
VEHICLE HE HELD BY THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE SAID
SAID THE DEPARTMENT CLOSER
ISSUE. OUR BILL I DE OF. AND I
THINK MOST OF US REMEMBER THE
FRUSTRATING REALITY OF FOR
SHOWING UP IN THE SUMMER OF TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WHEN
CUSTOMERS AND THIRD. ON WAY. IN
IN SOMEWHAT ON EXCUSABLE
CONDITIONS- INCLUDING OUTSIDE
IN HIGH TEMPERATURES THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS. ON CALL FOR
IN THE LEGISLATURE. START
HAVING HEARINGS IS STARTING
DEALING WITH THIS PROBLEM AND
WE MADE SOME PROGRESS HELLO I
THINK IT'S A PROBLEM. A
FRUSTRATING ALREADY. OF THE
REAL YOU FOR SHOWING UP- AT
THAT TIME. AND SO WE HAD A
HEARING IN OCTOBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHERE MY
COMMITTEE HELD ITS FIRST
HEARING AND THE AND- AT THAT
TIME THE OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINES IN KIND OF
LONG. FAR AWAY BUT THERE'S THE
ADDED ADEQUATE TIME. TO MAKE
IMPROVE. TO THE DMV PROCESSES
BY PROVIDING THE DMV WITH.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF SAY OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
SO THAT CUSTOMERS. ONE HALF TO
AIR UNDER THOSE LINES AGAIN. A
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATED A LOT OF
MONEY AND HER TESTIMONY ABOUT
IMPROVING THE PROCESS THE DAILY
IS NOT A LOT AND BRINGING-
INCLUDING OTHERS TEAM ARE.
OPENS AUTOMATING SPUR THE
FUNCTIONS STREAMLINING US THEIR
PROCESSES BUT HERE WE ARE
LESSEN SEVEN MONTHS FROM
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY DEADLINE
AND THE DEAL IS WELL SHORT THIS
GOAL PROVIDING THE SIXTEEN
MILLION CAL. WITH RELY.
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDING THE DMV
WITH ALL THE FUNDING THAT ARE
REQUESTED IT SEEMS CLEAR THAT
THEY END UP REMOTE CUSTOMER
SHORT OF THE GOAL. AND WE CAN
SAY THAT THE REAL ID PROBLEM AS
OF COURSE XIN WIDE PROBLEM WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THE- AND IT'S BY
THE WAY COURSE COMPOUNDED. BY
THE VIRUS- RESTRICTIONS- OF FOR
HEALTH REASONS AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO I WOULD INPUT ON THAT
TODAY BUT WHAT IS THIS REALLY
MAIN. I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
OUR HEARING OUR- SYSTEM OUR
TRAVEL INDUSTRY WHO CAN PROVIDE
US WITH RECESSED. THERE UP ON
THE FRONT LINE. TO FOR PEOPLE
THAT DO TRAVEL AND- THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DEAL WITH-
UNHAPPY CUSTOMERS CHORUS AND OF
COURSE THE ECONOMIC FALLOUT. OF
FROM THE REAL KEY ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE HERE BEFORE US. I'M ALSO
LOOKING TO- COME FORWARD TO
LEARNING HOW WITH CERTAIN
STATUS. THE WHAT'S WRONG WITH
THE LINE AND HOW OTHER GOING TO
PROCEED OVER THE SUMMER WITH
THE SO CALLED SUMMER SURGE THAT
PROBABLY WILL TAKE PLACE AND
WHAT THE DEAL BE PLANS ARE TO
DO ABOUT IT. HAVE WE STILL HAVE
SOME TIME. LITTLE TOO PRESS THE
ISSUE AND WITH A COORDINATED
EFFORT FROM THE DMV IN THE
TRAVEL AND SEE MAYBE WE CAN
MAKE THE PROBLEM- LESS BAD I
DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO GO
AWAY BUT I THINK IT COULD BE
MADE BETTER. FEDERAL US. MY
KOFI SHOOTER- A BUDGET- SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER TWO SIR WHAT
KOWSKI THE CHAIR OF THAT
COMMITTEE IF YOU LIKE TO SAVE
BOB. MAYBE SOMETHING HOPEFUL-
THE. SURE BALLOTS RIGHT IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN WE
START OUR ENDING THE DMV'S TO
ADD MORE POSITIONS TO IN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND IT READS LIKE A
SCRIPT WHEN THE LINE TO GET
ALONG ANYMORE I NEED TO GET
SPOKES OUT WE'RE NOW SPENDING
BUT IN FORTY. DOLLARS THIS YEAR.
FOR AS THE TAKEN TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM SO I AM I AM SURE
WE GET TO THE DMV WE'RE GOOD AT
IN A WE SHOULD HEAR WE HAVE THE
STAFF AND IS READY. DEAL WE
HAVE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SO THE PUBLIC SHOULD BE
AWARE THAT WE'VE RESPONDED WITH
STAFF WE'VE INCREASED THE
EFFICIENCIES OF. A SERVICE IT I
FEEL LIKE IT'S OF THE DREAMS
YOU KNOW IF WE BUILD IT THEY
WILL COME MAYBE AND WE BUILD IT
WE'VE WE'VE THAT DEAR. YEP LAW
OFFICE BE READY TO ROLL RIGHT
NOW TO HAVE THIS ST LUCIA OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING BUT IF
THE PUBLIC DOESN'T SHOW UP IN
MORE EACH EMPLOYEE UNTIL. HER
DEATH. THAT'S A PROBLEM AND I
PRESUME WE'RE GETTING HERE
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS ON OCTOBER
SECOND WITH ANGRY PEOPLE AT
BURBANK AIRPORT OR AT WILL
RIGHT IN FRONT OF THE SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES OR YOU KNOW. YOU GET
THIRD AT THE TOURIST THAT WHEN
IT COMES THE BEAUTIFUL- IN THE
SUMMER. THE THERE IS WE- I
THINK THE FUNDING IS THERE BUT
WE'RE SO WE'RE HAVING AN OVER
ACTIVE FIND OUT ABOUT THAT
FUNDING LEVEL. MR FOR TWO THE
DO. THIS IS THEY'RE PRESENTED
TODAY OKAY. OUR TO HAVE THE-
OPENING REMARKS FROM ANY OTHER
SENATOR THAT WOULD LIKE TO SAY
ANYTHING THIS POINT. OKAY THEN
WE WILL START AND LET'S BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST PLANNER- WE HAVE.
THREE PEOPLE WE LIKE TO HAVE
INCOME FOR NOW HAVE FRANK
MILLER FROM HOLLYWOOD BURBANK
AIRPORT. LAUREN BUYER VICE
PRESIDENT- SECURITY- FOR
AIRLINES FOR AMERICA AIRLINE-
BUT TED PRESIDENT OF HIS VISIT
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR ALL
FOR BEING HERE- I THINK WE'LL
START WITH FRANK. GOOD GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS FRANK MILLER
AND I M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE HOLLYWOOD BURBANK
AIRPORT. AND SERVICE THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIRPORTS COUNCIL. THE CARD FOR
ITS CAST WAS COMPRISED OF THAT
THIRTY ONE COMMERCIAL AIRPORTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION TRAVEL
PASSENGERS TRANSIT THROUGH
CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS EACH YEAR
MORE THAN ANY OTHER STATE. AS
EVENTS OF THE LAST FEW WEEKS OF
HIGHLY HIGHLIGHTED CALIFORNIA
AIRPORTS SERVICE GATEWAYS FOR
INTERNATIONAL PASSENGERS AND
SAFE AND SECURE MANAGEMENT OF
OUR FIRST BASE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS IS
OUR HIGHEST. READY WITH REGARD
TO DE FORCE WORRIED ABOUT
OCTOBER. THE TASK HANNITY DMV'S
AROUND THE COUNTRY IS DAUNTING
ESPECIALLY THE SIZE OF THE TASK
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT CAN YOU
PULL THAT MIKE A LITTLE CLOSER.
YOU FOR SERVICE THIS. THAT'S
GOOD. CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE DMV SINCE
THEY ARE APPROACH US IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND THE DEPARTMENT
HAS PRESENTED AT TO A DIRECTOR
THINGS INCLUDE DISCUSSION WITH
THE DE RECTOR AT OUR MOST
RECENT LAST. THE DIEM. PORTS
ELECTRONIC AND PRINCE AND
MESSAGING THAT WE BEGAN TO
DISPLAY IT SECURITY CHECKPOINT
AREAS IN LATE TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WE'RE ALSO WERE. A N. CREATING
MORE SIGNAGE TO A PLACE AROUND
THE AIRPORT TERMINAL BURBANK
AND I'M SURE THE OTHER AIRPORTS
AROUND THE STATE ARE DOING THE
SAME THING. BELIEVE ALERT FREE
TO THE NEW REQUIRE. THE DMV HAS
ALSO SET UP INFORMATION TABLES
INSIDE TERMINALS AT SOME
AIRPORTS THOUGH AIRPORTS HAVE
ALSO RECOMMENDED THE DMB
ESTABLISHED TEMPORARY READ THE
ENROLLMENT CENTERS IN PORTRAIT
ALMOST SIMILAR TO TSA PRE CHECK
IN ROMAN CENTER AT AIRPORTS.
FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CEASE LETTER THEN TRANSFER XIN
SECRETARY. DIRECT ANSWER THE
DMV TO. URGING THE STATE'S OF
THE AND SETTING UP SAT AND
ROMAN CENTERS AT AIRPORTS. WE
BELIEVE THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PROCESS REAL. ID
APPLICATIONS AT AIRPORTS FOR
MORE FREE CAN TRAVEL. MISSION
AND MINNESOTA HAVE BOTH BOARD
RELY. ENROLL TENORS. LAST WEEK
I JOINED OTHER AIRPORTS FROM
AROUND THE COUNTRY IN
WASHINGTON DC AND RELY D. WAS A
PRIMARY TOPIC OF DISCUSSION.
CONGRESS IS KEENLY AWARE TURN
AS A HERE FROM AIRPORTS
AIRLINES AND THE TRAVEL
INDUSTRY. TWO STATES- TOLD HAVE
NOT YET BEGUN TO ISSUE REAL
THESE. IN ADDITION TO THE T.
SHS IMPLEMENTED A HIRING FREEZE
WITH NO DEFINITIVE DATEABLE
AIRING PHRASE MAY BE LEFT.
RUSHING BACK IN DEADLINE I WON
PRECHECK AND GLOBAL ENTRY TO
SATISFY THE REAL ID REQUIREMENT
SHOULD ALL BE OPTIONS FOR
CONSIDER. BUT WHAT WORRIES ARE
POOR MAN. I'M DOUBLE PERIODIC
PASSENGER THE TWENTY TWENTY AND
A SEASONED TRAVELER WHO NEVER
GOT THE MEMO. AND ALSO PASSAGE
TO MAY DEPART AN AIRPORT PRIOR
TO OCTOBER FIRST AND THEN TRY
TO RETURN HOME AND HAVE ARE
TOLD THAT THE CONSOLE OR BOARD
AN AIRPLANE. THE IMPACT INJURES
NINE SECURITY CLEARANCES
UNKNOWN. LARGE NUMBERS COULD
SLOW SECURITY LINES AND WOULD
CERTAINLY INCREASED AIRLINE
TICKET COUNTER CONGESTION. WELL
AIRLINES ACCOMMODATE PASSENGERS
IN WAY FEES TO CHANGE YOUR
FLIGHT. OPERATIONALLY AIRPORT
LINES COULD BE CHALLENGED TO
MANAGE THE EXTRACTION AFTER
LUGGAGE FROM THE BAGGAGE SYSTEM
BELONGING TO PASSENGERS LATER
TONIGHT CLEARANCE AT THE
SECURITY CHECKPOINT. THE DMV
MOVE FORWARD AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE AIRPORTS CONTINUE TO
MESSAGE TO PASSENGERS AND TO
CONGRESS AND HELPS COVER OCULUS
SAVE. WE ALSO CONTINUE TO
RECOMMEND TEMPORARY REAL ID
ENROLLMENT CENTERS EITHER
MOBILE OR STATIONARY AT
CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS. AIRPORTS
WOULD WELCOME THAT ENHANCE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DMV AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT A LOT OF
AIRPORTS WOULD BE READY TO GO
TOMORROW THE SPACE
ACCOMMODATION FOR THE DAY.
THANK YOU FOR I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
WILL ASK QUESTIONS AT THE END
OF THE PANEL SO LARA BUYER
YOU'RE NEXT THANK YOU. IT IS
ALREADY OKAY THANK YOU A CLOSE
TO YOUR CERTAINLY GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEES MY NAME IS
LAUREN BUYER I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR SECURITY AND
FACILITATION AT. IS FOR AMERICA.
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE LADY. EFFECTIVE
OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TRAVELERS WILL BE REQUIRED TO
HAVE A REAL ID COMPLIANT
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR ALTERNATE
APPROVED IDENTIFICATION TO US
THROUGH TSA CHECKPOINTS AT
AIRPORTS FINAL IN FOR DEADLINE
OF THE LADY ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
FIVE. COMMITTEE LEADERSHIP IN
AWARENESS ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
DISRUPTION TO AIR TRAVEL IN
OCTOBER OF THIS YEAR FOR THOSE
PASSENGERS WHO ARE NOT PREPARED
WITH THEIR REALIZE HE COMPLIANT
LICENSE OR- BY. TEN US AIRLINES
BEEN WORKING CLOSE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AND THE TRANSPORTATION SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION TO AMPLIFY THEIR
REAL ID MESSAGING. TO DIRECT
TRAVELERS TO THE APPROPRIATE
WEBSITES TO ENSURE THEIR
EDUCATED ABOUT HOW TO OBTAIN A
REAL ID COMPLIANT
IDENTIFICATION CARD. OVER THE
LAST YEAR A FOR A IN OUR
MEMBERS HAVE UNDERTAKEN A
VARIETY TO THESE TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS ISSUE. FOR EXAMPLE. OUR
TRAVEL AND DINNER IS ASKING
THEM TO JOIN US IN MAKING THE
PUBLIC MORE AWARE OF THE
UPCOMING DEADLINE. SINCE CAN IS
IN MAY STILL HAVE THE CHOICE
BETWEEN A NON COMPLIANT AND
COMPLIANT ID THE STATE'S NEED
TO PLAY A KEY ROLE IN ENSURING
THAT CONSUMERS UNDERSTAND. THAT
EVEN SOME NEW IDEAS MAY NOT BE
COMPLIANT FOR AIR TRAVEL UBER
OF YOUR- WE ALSO ASK THE
GOVERNOR'S TO CONSIDER REVISED.
OCCASIONS THERE RESIDENTS TO
MAKE OR CALL- THE IS BETWEEN
RELY DE AND NON COMPLIANT I
TECHIES. WE'VE ALSO BROUGHT
TOGETHER- TSA'S COMMUNICATIONS
TEAMS WITH OUR COMMUNICATORS
FROM THE TRAVEL INDUSTRY
ORGANIZATION. ORGANIZATION
INCLUDING AIRLINES AIRPORTS AND
OTHER GROUPS IN JUNE OF LAST
YEAR TO BEGIN WROTE
COLLABORATION ON OUTREACH
EFFORTS. WE PARTICIPATED IN TWO
DAYS PRESS CONFERENCE ON
OCTOBER FIRST OF LAST YEAR THE
ONE YEAR TO THE ENFORCEMENT
DEADLINE TO HIGHLIGHT OUR
RESPECTIVE CAMPAIGNS. WE'VE
PREPARED A REAL ID TOOL KIT FOR
USE BY LEGISLATORS AT THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
AS WELL AS FOR IT THE
COMMUNICATORS TO HELP GET THE
WORD OUT AND I'VE BROUGHT THAT
HERE TODAY WITH ME. WITH A REAL
ID WEBSITE IT'S REAL ID FAX DOT
COM. TO FURTHER EDUCATE
TRAVELERS THE NEW RULES. THE
WEBPAGE INCLUDES AN INTERACTIVE
STATE BY STATE MAP TO ADDRESS
DIFFERENCES IN STATE
IDENTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS.
THE WEBSITE ALL FEATURES OUR
THIRTY REAL ID COMMERCIAL WHICH
AIRED ON A LOCAL DC- STATION
DURING THE SUPERBOWL PREGAME
COVERAGE. WE'VE TESTIFIED IN
FRONT OF THE SENATE COMMERCE
SECURITY SUBCOMMITTEE ON REAL
ID A AND- PARTICIPATED IN
NUMEROUS ROUND TABLE SOME
BRIEFINGS TO RAISE
CONGRESSIONAL YES. WE ALSO
PROVIDE REGULAR MEDIA
STATEMENTS AND INTERVIEWS TO
HELP AMPLIFY THE MESSAGING. US
LINES ALSO ARE EMPLOYING A
VARIETY OF METHODS TO
PROMINENTLY SHARE INFORMATION
AND COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
CUSTOMERS I SUCH AS POSTING
NOTICES OF THE CHANGE ON THEIR
WEBSITES IN FLIGHT MAGAZINES
AND SOCIAL MEDIA. AS WELL
SHOWING VIDEOS ON THERE AND
THIRTEEN. MANY CARRIERS ARE
PROVIDING TRAVELERS WITH USEFUL
INFORMATION IN EMAILS
RESERVATION CONFIRMATIONS AND
CHECK AND REMINDERS. AND IN
ADDITION THE AIRLINES
THEMSELVES ARE ALSO PRO
ACTIVELY ENGAGING WITH AIRPORTS
TRAVEL AGENCIES CORPORATE
CLIENTS AND ELECT OFFICIALS TO
HEIGHTEN AWARENESS ABOUT THE
REAL ID. SINCE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY AND THE
TRANSPORTATION SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION HAVE NOT GIVEN
ANY INDICATION OF A WILLINGNESS
TO EXTEND THE DEADLINE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO KEEPING UP THE
MENTAL EDUCATING THE PUBLIC IN
ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE TWO
POINT FOUR MILLIONALL WHO
TRAVEL EVERY SINGLE DAY ABLE TO
FLOW THROUGH THE SYSTEM IS FREE
AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU. KENNEDY
FOR TO YOUR QUESTIONS. VERY
MUCH JOB CAROLINE WOULD AT AT
THE TERROR THANK YOU CAROLINE
AND CAROLINE'S A PRESIDENT OF
AND CO A VISIT CALIFORNIA DO
YOU RATE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE VISIT CALIFORNIA'S- A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP- WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH KOBE IS WE
ARE IN. PROFIT THE WITH TWENTY
ONE. INVESTORS FOR THE THREE TO
SUPPORT THE INDUSTRIES A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMY HEARING
CALIFORNIA OR THE NUMBER ONE
TRAVEL DESTINATION THE UNITED
STATES. US THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS
WE HAVE A LOT TO LOSE IF WE SEE
SIGNIFICANT TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS
ON OCTOBER FIRST AS A MATTER OF
FACT WORKING VERY CLOSE US
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION ON RELATED
IT'S AND GETTING. AND THEY-
MADE STUDY. AND INDICATED
THERE'S A POP. AT LEAST THAT
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE
COULD BE TURNED AWAY ON THE
FIRST DAY OF THIS REQUIREMENT
ARE COSTING THE US TRAVEL
ECONOMY FORTY MILLION A DAY OR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO MILLION.
AND TRAVELS IN IN JUST ONE WEEK
OWN ALL BELIEVE ONLY 16% OF
AMERICANS ARE ARE REAL DE
COMPLIANCE AT THIS POINT. UP IT
WILL HAVE A WE CAN IMPACT US
INTO. SINCE WE HAVE ABOUT 12%
SHARE OF THE MARKET CALIFORNIA
STANDS TO LOSE ABOUT FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS A DAY IN
SPENDING OR AND TOTAL WE COULD
BE SEEN A DROP OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MIL. OFF FROM
A LACK OF WELL I BE COMPLIANT I
FIRST TRAVELING US SO WE HAVE
STEPPED IN AS WELL TO TRYTO
AMPLIFY THE MESSAGE. HAVE A-
THREE MILLION DOLLAR GOAL
PROGRAM OF WORK TO ENTER TIONAL
AND WE ACT HAVE THREE MILLION
FOLLOWERS ACROSS ALL OF OUR
CHANNELS AND SO PART OF THAT
EFFORT HAS BEEN GO UP. OUR
DIGITAL. SOCIAL CHANGE.
CHANNELS MESSAGING JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE ARE BRAND NEW VISITOR
GUIDE THIS- AND RECENTLY COMING
OUT IN JANUARY WE PRINT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND- EASILY
THERE'S ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND LETTER IT ONLINE AS
WELL AND WE HAVE REAL I. WELL
AS A CODE ARE. VISIT IN THE TO
THAT WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA NOW
BLOG THAT HAS TWO POINTS A
SEVEN SOCIABLE- MEDIA
FOLLOWERS- ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND SUBSCRIBERS SO
WE HAVE MET JEAN AS PART OF
THAT HOT. REPUBLICAN THAT OUR
GUIDE- AMPLE FINE THE BEST WAY
TO SEE CALIFORNIA'S THROUGH OUR
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND MILES OF
ROADWAYS AND EIGHT HUNDRED
FOUR. COASTLINE IN THAT GUIDE
WILL BE THESE- SOME CONTENT DEL
DEDICATED TO REAL IDE BECAUSE
SO MANY PEOPLE- DO FLY DRIVE
VACATIONS VERY CRITICAL IN
THESE LINKS TO THE AIRPORTS AND
MERYL- THANK. WILL CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT OTHER CHANNELS- THAT WE
CAN HELP AMPLE FI AND SUPPORT
ALL OF YOU IN THIS MESSAGING
AND I THINK WE'VE GOT SOME
CHALLENGES THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
IF. YOU KNOW THE CORONA BY SEND
AND CONSUMERS BEING CONSUMED BY
THAT MESSAGING AND SO IT MAKES
IT A LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR US NOW. AND THREE. I THINK
IT'S SIMPLY NOT HOLDING THIS
HEARING AND THAT WE HAVE THAT
SYNERGY BECAUSE IN GETTING IT'S
ALL ABOUT REACH FREQUENCY AND
LAYER MESSAGING SO YOU FINALLY
KIND I CAN BREAK THROUGH TO THE
TRAVELING DOES IT HAVE ANSWER
QUESTION. THANK YOU TIME. THE
THREE OF YOU AS IS THERE
ANYBODY INDICATION FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO. DEFERRED
THE DEADLINE FOR THE REAL ID.
YOU'VE HEARD OF. THIS QUESTION
SO I'LL ASK IT YEAH OR HEARING.
WHICH CHAIR IN THE IT WHAT WHAT
I'M HEARING IS THAT MOST LIKELY
THE EXTENSION WILL NOT HAPPEN.
AND BECAUSE OF THE TWO BECAUSE
THAT DOES DATE BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IN THE AND THEY
FEEL THAT THE TIMEIS NOW TO.
ENACT THIS EVEN- WITH. CURRENT
HEALTH ISSUES THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE UNITED STATES.
THAT DID NOT COME TO THE
DISCUSSION I HAD. THERE THERE
ARE GETTING THERE ARE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE VIRUS BUT DIDN'T THEY
WERE IN RAISING THAT AS PART OF
THE DISCUSSION WITH WITH ME ON
THE REAL THE- IT. ALSO YES SIR
AS AS THEN IN MY TESTIMONY- WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANY INDICATION
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THEY INTEND TO EXTEND THE
DEADLINE- AND I WOULD ALL-
THAT- EVEN. AND AS WE GET
CLOSER TO OCTOBER IF WE WERE IF
THEY WERE SAID STARTING TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. OF THAT
STILL WILL OF THIS PROBLEM
EVENTUALLY I KNOW YOU KNOW IT
IS A CONGRESSIONAL MANDATE AND
THEREFORE- FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T. NEED TO ADD TO IT FOR
SO. FROM OUR SIDE THAT WERE
COMMITTED. OF UT CONTINUING
THAT OUT. TO GET THE STATURE.
OF COMPLY OF. THE SENATE. SOME
OF THE OTHER PANEL OF WITNESSES
ON MY AND WE MIGHT SEE SOME
MOVEMENT RIGHT BEFORE OCTOBER
FIRST JUST DEPENDING BUT-
THEY'RE HOLDING WHEN OUR SMALL
YEAH RIGHT. JUST TO CREATE THAT
PRESSURE LIKE A LOT OF THE-
BLAME FOR THE RELATED PROBLEM-
NATIONAL QUESTION- I KIND OF
LIKE TO KNOW- IN OTHER STATES.
IN THE UNITY SPECIFICALLY TALK
ABOUT THE AIRPORT WE WOULD
BURBANK AIRPORT AND OTHER
AIRPORTS ARE WHAT KIND OF A
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
AND AIRPORTS EXIST IN OTHER
STATES THAT WE DON'T HAVE. HERE
AND THEN PERHAPS. CAROLINE WITH
THE TRAVEL. THAT WE CAN. IF YOU
CAN ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS
MISTER CHAIRMAN I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE MINNEAPOLIS ST PAUL
AIRPORT I MENTIONED IN MY
REMARKS AT A SODA HAS MOVED
FORWARD WITH WORKING WITH THE
D. E. THE- PULLED. IT ONLINE.
SODA AND THEN THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY WHEN THEY'RE
PASSING THROUGH THE AIRPORT TO
PICK UP AND THEIR DOCUMENTATION
AND THAT DOES REQUIRE THAT THEY
THE PHOTOS THE AIRPORT AND THEN
THE IT IS ISSUED THEM IN A DAY
TO REP TOLD ME THAT THEY ALSO
HAVE. THE PARTY WHERE THE-
PROCESS AT THE YEAR. HAS PORT.
TO THEIR GET IN OUR PARTY. THE
PARKING SO THERE IS A
COLLABORATION HAPPENING. ON THE
WAY TO THE GETTING THROUGH THE
GATE THEY HAVE TO HAVE ONE WILL
STOP JUST AT ONE TIME BY. OKAY
SELF RIGHT. YES THAT DONE BY A
PRIVATE COMPANY. HE DID NOT SAY
AND I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION BY THAT IS I CAN
CERTAINLY PROVIDE TO YOU LATER
ABOUT THE OTHERS. NO I SEE-
MASK COORDINATION BY THE TRAVEL
INDUSTRY NOW I EASE SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO EVEN THE TRAVEL
INDUSTRY WASN'T COORDINATING ON
THIS FOR CALIFORNIA THEY
IMPACTS AND OPPORTUNITIES I
THINK ARE THERE 82% OF OUR
TAVEL SPENDING ACTUALLY IS
CALIFORNIANS TRAVELING AROUND
CALIFORNIA THAT'S BROWN AND-
BUT NONE I THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY IN TERMS OF THE
SATURATION OF WHAT WERE SEEN AS
TO BE ABLE TO. RIDLEY HAVE
SYSTEM. RIGHT AT CALIFORNIANS I
AM IN AIRPORTS ALMOST EVERY
DAY- BURBANK'S DONE A GREAT JOB
BUT THERE'S OTHERS THAT IT'S I
A HE SAY IT TO IT IT'S A HIT
AND MISS BUT I ACTUALLY THINK
THE- ALSO. TSA AT THE FEDERAL
APPARATUS AND I THINK THERE'S A
LACK OF CONSISTENCY WHEN YOU'RE
BEING ASKED TO SHOW YOUR ID
THERE- IF IT'S NOT REAL ID
THERE SHOULD BE A VERBAL
SOMETIMES THERE'S A SIGN AT THE
AIRPORT BUT WHY VERBAL IT'S THE
BREAK THROUGH OF MESSAGING WE
NEED A CONSUMER EVEN A BLIND TO
THE SIDE BUT IT AUDIO SO TSA.
IF I IF I MIGHT SIR. FROM THE
TRAVEL INDUSTRY SIDE AND AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL WE- LAST YEAR
EARLY LAST YEAR BUILT A
COALITION WITH OUR TRUCK
MINISTRY PARTNERS- SUPPORTS
REPRESENTING THE AIRPLANES FROM
MYSELF BUT- ALSO THE AIRPORT
ASSOCIATIONS. US TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION DOUBLE BUSINESS
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION ON OUR
INTENT THERE WILL IS- TO A POOL
OF RESOURCES IF YOU WELL TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT OTHER ELEMENTS
OF OUR HISTORY ARE DOING TO THE
WORD OUT. I'M TO DE CONFLICT%
WHERE PASTA. ALL TO. UP AND-
COME UP WITH SOME BEST. IN
TERMS OF COMMUNICATION TO THE
PUBLIC ON THAT WE COULD THEN
SHARE WITH OUR WITH OUR MEMBERS
AND WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS. SO I
THINK THAT KEY ELEMENT HERE IN
TERMS OF THE QUESTION OF THE-
COLLABORATION AND OTHER STATES
WITH THE- I WOULD. ON IT VARIES.
VARIES WIDELY BUT THAT'S
PRECISELY AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
WE IN TRYING TO BUILD THOSE
BEST PRACTICES IN PUSH THOSE
OUT. TO THE- HELLO. I WOULD. OF
T. PAY ALSO DOING PART TO GET
THE WORD OUT THEY'VE BEEN GOOD
PARTNERS WITH US AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AS I MENTIONED
IN MY TO MONY WITH NUMBER
ENGAGEMENTS WITH THEM TO TRY TO
A LOT MESSAGE AND AN AMPLIFIER.
AND I'M I'M NOT WHERE I LAST
INSTRUCT. HER ALL. AT AIRPORTS
TO ADVISE. PASSENGERS INTO OF
THE TRAVEL DOCUMENT CHECKER
THE- OFFICER STANDING THERE THE
TEXTURE ID. ON THAT WHEN
SOMEONE PRESENTS THAT ARE NON
COMPLIANT IDEA TO ADVISE THE
ASSN- THAT WANED A LITTLE BIT
OVER THE HOLIDAY PERIOD. BUT
WE'VE BEEN IN YOU KNOW DAILY
COMMUNICATION WITH THEM AND
THEY HAVE A SHORT US- BUT THEY
WILL- REINFORCE THEIR DIRECTION
INTO THE FIELD- TO START UP
THAT MESSAGING INDIVIDUAL
PASSENGER AGAIN AND SO WE AGREE
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT. A
SHORT CLOSE CENTER DAHLE DOLLY
ANALYSTS ARE MORE LOG I BELIEVE.
SO SIR WORK STATE AND CEREMONY
OR- THANK YOU I DID BATES. WE
WERE HAVING QUITE A FEW- FOLKS
THAT WE CAUGHT CASE WORKS THERE
CALLING OUR OFFICE THERE TO THE
INFORMATION THAT. SEEMS TO FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS IS THE
INFORMATION TO IDENTIFY WHO
THEY ARE SO IN OUR CASE HINES
TALKED FOR ON ONE CASE I HAD
BECAUSE OF. WHO IS TRYING TO
LOCATE THE BIRTH CERTIFICATE
IT'S A IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR HIM
A. B. ANOTHER STATE. AND THE
COURT WHERE HE- ON ON BUT WHEN.
ACTUALLY GET HIS BIRTH
CERTIFICATE A WAS EIGHTY THREE
OLD IS THERE ANYBODY DOING.
CAMPAIGN TO SAY HEY THESE ARE
THE THINGS YOU NEED THAT WILL
QUALIFY YOU TO GET. I DIESEL
WITH ACTUALLY GO. THERE GETTING
THROUGH THE PROCESS DOT HAPPEN
TO GO BACK IN FOR THURSDAY. IN
THE ANIMAL LITTLE WANTING IT
WHAT IS THE NAY NEED TO TAKE TO
GET THE REAL ID. UP SO. AT THE
SHORT ANSWER IS YES- BUT IT'S
BUT IT'S COMPLICATED AS A AS
WITH MOST THINGS- THE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS DO VERY STATE BY
STATE. SO IT'S CHALLENGING AT A
NATIONAL LEVEL WELL TO BE ABLE
TO PUT IN SIMPLE TERMS EXACT
FIREMAN BECAUSE OF. THIS SO THE
WAY THAT WE HAVE- ATTEMPTED TO
ADDRESS AT IS IN OUR
COMMUNICATIONS I MENTIONED WE
SEE. AWAY REAL THE FACT COM
CLUE BUT STATE BY STATE. SO
THAT THAT RIGHT IN EACH STATE.
LOSE OF WHERE. THEY LIVE FOR
EXAMPLE CAO. AND THEN DIG
DEEPER INTO THE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS OF CAL YEAH.
GOVERNOR WITHIN AIRPORT THE
PERSPECTIVE ON IT WE ARE NOW
JUST BEGINNING TO PUT TOGETHER
ON SOCIAL MEDIA INFORMATION
THAT GOES OUT TO OUR CUSTOMERS
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THE
HAVING AND ARE PLACING A
WEBSITE INFORMATION. AND THE
TERM. VIDEOS THAT TO HELP BE
ABLE TO PLAY IN THE GATE AREAS
AND ONE OF THE KEY ELEMENTS OF
THAT IS EXACTLY YOUR QUESTION
WHAT DO YOU NEED TO TAKE FIRST.
IN ORDER TO. TRY TO PROCESS.
THIRTY TO. I'M ASSUMING THAT
THE WE GET THE CALLS IN OUR
OFFICE ABOUT THAT AFTER THE
DAVID HIGHLY FRUSTRATED WITH
THE PROCESS AT LEAST THAT'S
BEEN OUR EXPERIENCE A MOBILE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF THE
ACTUALLY JUST CONTINUE ALONG TO
THE THERE'S- BUILDING
PERMISSION. THE OF THE PROCESS
GET THROUGH THE PROCESS A
LITTLE LEAGUE I'M GLAD TO HEAR
THAT YOU HAVE I WROTE ON THAT
WEBSITE AND I'LL BE POSTING AS
WELL TO LET MY CONSTITUENTS
KNOW WHERE THEY CAN GO TO. AIR
FOR WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO FACE
WHEN THEY AND TO. GET THE REAL
ID YOU. WORK OUT. OKAY SO ALL
OF THIS SERVICE. ARE YOU ON
THIS. BUT YOUR TO YOUR TO I
ASSUME THE BEST PRACTICE OR THE
MESSAGING THE BEST MESSAGE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE ONE THAT THE
CONSUMER DOES SOMEONE IS AT
OCTOBER SET IT ON THE AIRPLANE
THAT MESSAGE WILL BE DELIVERED
LACKS LIKE. TO ALL PEOPLE HAVE
TAKEN IT THE SECOND BEST TO
JUST COULD YOU TALK ABOUT BEST
PRACTICES AND- WHAT DO YOU. HOW
US TRY TO BET WHAT THAT SECOND
BEST MESSAGE RIGHT NOW IS OR
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM THESE
OTHER. AIRPORTS OR WITH OTHER
HI INDEED INDUSTRY OR THE OTHER
AIRLINES HAVE YOU KNOW WHAT'S
FILTERING IN. DON'T WAIT. DON'T
WAIT OF THE POINT IS ALREADY
BEEN MADE THAT- YOU KNOW WE
WE'RE IN MARCH- BUT- EVERYONE
GOING IN SEPTEMBER CANNOT
CANNOT BE THE ANSWER- SO IT'S
SIMPLY DON'T WAIT AND IF YOU
HAVE A AN ALTERNATE FORM OF
IDENTIFICATION IN THAT A BIT
LOUDER. SAMPLE PORT. THAT FINE.
BUT THE BUT YOU KNOW MOST
PEOPLE I THINK DON'T CARRY
THEIR PASSPORT WITH THEM ON A
DOMESTIC TRIP SET SOMETHING
THAT THEY NEED TO KEEP IN MIND.
IT IS THE- IS THAT- YOUR
MESSAGE ALSO THAT CARRY YOUR
PASSPORT OR YOU KNOW WE WILL.
WE'RE HAVING YOUR PASSPORT S.
R. AND US TRAVEL AS I SAID HAD
PUT TOGETHER THAT TOOL KIT FOR
WHAT WE CALL BE TO BE MESSAGING
OR BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
MESSAGING THAT WE'VE LOOKED AND
SO ARE ASSISTANCE PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE IT'S- I'M- I
AGREE THE IT. THE FIRST AND FOR
MOST THE MESSAGING SHOULD WAIT
BUT WE DO MESSAGE THAT PASSPORT
OR OTHER FORMS OF ID- YOU KNOW
ARE ARE ALSO APPROACH AND BAD.
WORDS INTO. PUT THAT AS A
SECONDARY MESSAGE BECAUSE A LOT
OF AND SHE SAID A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T TRAVEL WHAT PASS WORKS
THAT'LL BE GREAT FOR THE SECOND
SHOP BUT THERE MAY. I HAVE A-
AND RELATED QUESTION I WANTED.
FOUR TO OCTOBER SECOND. AND WE
HAVE MADE HIM AND BURBANK EVERY
EVERY LINE AT UNITED AIRLINES
OR SOUTHWEST AIR EVERY EVERY
AIRLINES TOURIST INDUSTRY ALL
THESE. PORTABLE SO YOU HAVE-
HER HAPPENING. HOW DO YOU GUYS
RESPOND WILL LAST DMV ABOUT
ABOUT THAT BUT HOW DO YOU FOLKS
RESPOND WHEN THEY CAN DON'T GET
ON THE AIRLINE AND ALL AND ALL
THAT. HOW TO SET WHICH- THE
PLAN. UNFORTUNATELY PLAN FOR US
ON OCTOBER SECOND IS TO HAVE A
VERY VISIBLE POLICE FORCE WE
KNOW THAT THEY'RE A BIT SAID TO
BE DROPPING TO MANAGE THE
EMOTION. PEOPLE HAVE. NOT TO BE
VERY AGGRESSIVE WITH THEM BUT
AT THE SAME TIME TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT FOR THOSE
PASSENGERS WHO ARE COMPLY AND
THE ABILITY TO GET THROUGH THE
TERMINAL. BUT HAVING A DEAL.
ALL THAT FOR WHATEVER REASON
HAVE HAVE NOT REALIZE THAT THEY
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GRAPPLE ONTO
AN AIRPLANE SO. THAT'S OUR
BIGGEST TURN IS. IN OF PEOPLE
THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH- AND
HOW LONG IT'LL TAKE FOR US TO
WORK THROUGH THAT. JUST CHAD-
FROM THE AIRLINE PERSPECTIVE
WE'VE COMMUNICATED TO THE FIVE
GOVERNMENT THAT- IT'S REALLY AN
UNTENABLE SITUATION- IF THAT
WERE TO THAT THE ANSWER SIMPLY
CAN'T BE ALL OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS CAN'T BOARD- TSA
HAS A- S. ALREADY OUT RIGHT NOW
IF SOMEONE SHOWS UP AT A CHECK
POINT WITHOUT. OUT WITHOUT
IDENTIFICATION- AND- TSA IS
COMMUNICATED UNFORTUNATELY THAT
THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE SYSTEM
WOULD BE OVERWHELMED GIVEN THE
CURRENT. AND ANALYST DURATION
THIRTY FOUR FIVE. RYAN OF
RESOURCE I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN AND CLEAR PEOPLE
THROUGH. THAT PASSED SO WE ARE
OUT BILLION GATE. THE I ON
ALTERNATE. THAT WE BE ANYTHING
AN INDIVIDUAL SPORT IS THERE
ANY WITH. INSERT YOUR BOOK YOU
GET YOU SEE. MESSAGE TO SAVE
PASS OR YOU KNOW DOUBLE THE
BRING YOUR IF YOU'RE IN DOUBT
WHAT YOUR ID BRING YOUR
PASSPORT WITH YOU WERE YOU GUYS
WOULD SAY BRING YOUR SUPPORT
JUST TO MAKE YOUR OWN GOING ON.
OUR YOU'RE GOING. YES THE
AIRLINE ALREADY COMMUNICATING
WITH PASSENGERS IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS AS AS I
MENTIONED IN THE TESTIMONY BUT
THAT WOULD INCLUDE OUT REAL ID
REMINDERS- IN INCLUDING. OR
OTHER FORMS OF OLD AND
IDENTIFICATION- IN THEIR
RESERVATION CONFIRMATIONS IN
CHECK AND REMINDERS EXCEPT
ARRESTED THAT COMMUNICATION IS
OCCURRING. ACCENTOR MORE LIKE
I'M SORRY. I'M COMING OUT OF A-
CERTIFIED BUT ACCOUNTING
BACKGROUND APRIL FIFTEENTH IS
COMING AND WE WOULD ALWAYS JOKE
THAT NOTHING WOULD GET DONE IF
IT WEREN'T FOR THE LAST MINUTE.
REALLY KIND OF SHOWS. FIFTEEN
WE HAD THIS BIG SPIKE TO
WORKLOAD. SO I FIND IT
INTERESTING THAT YOU YOU BEEN
MESSAGING. BUT IT IS OLD THE
REAL ID ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
FIVE. I GET PEOPLE OBSERVING
THE ROOM THAT THAT'S A LIFETIME.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING WHEN DID
YOUR MESSAGING START TEN YEARS
AGO FIVE YEARS AGO. WHAT WE
WOULDN'T IF YOU HAVE ANY
DOCUMENTATION THAT SHOWS GET
YOUR REAL LIKE THE- I'M JUST
CURIOUS YEAH I MEAN I'LL TELL
ON OURSELVES OUR MESSAGING
STARTED- AS PART OF A DEAL WITH
THE INDUSTRY ABOUT A YEAR AGO.
AND JUST ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
ON. THE WITH OUR SOCIAL
CHANNELS AND WE DO LIVE SOCIAL
MEDIA. CENTERMON AROUND THE
WORLD THE MINUTE BY MINUTE SO
ABOUT TWO WEEKS OUT WE WILL-
LOOK AT DROPPING IN THAT
SECONDARY MASTER GENE AND
PASSED THIS- AND OTHER
COMPLAINT FORMS OF ID BUT WE
DON'T DO THAT NOW TO. A THROUGH
U. S. TRAVEL I DON'T WANT
INCLUDE THE AIRPORT THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING ON A LOT LONGER-
ABOUT IT. BECAUSE IT YOU KNOW
YOU CAN AT ALL THE MESS YOU.
BUT A CONSUMER. TO LESS. YOU
KNOW SO FOR US WE THIS IS
MESSAGE BOARD DOING THIS TO HOW.
WE'RE NOT REQUIRED TO DO IT AND
WE AND- HOW AND TO. PUT THE
FOURTH WHERE PEOPLE ARE GONNA
CAN THEM SO THEY'VE GOT TO BE
WILLING TO LOOK. AT ARTIST OUT
OF THAT. STE THE REAL ID THE
FIRST OF JANUARY TWO EIGHTEEN
SO THAT'S CORRECT AT WHEN WE
START LEASE START ISSUE. AND
WHY WOULD THAT BE THIRTY YEARS
AFTER THE WITH IT. RE WE COULD
BE DOING THIS. I I'M JUST I'M
SORRY IT SEEMS LIKE A QUESTION
BUT I I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW COME WE STARTED MESSING
A YEAR AGO AND YOU DID IT
BECAUSE I. URGENT AT. BUT IS A
THIS. AND NOW HERE WE ARE THE
MINUTE. AND THE DMV IS. NOT
PLAN FOR THE MANPOWER TO A
THIRD THIS IS ALL THE OTHER
THING IS AN HONOR MOTOR VOTER
AND YOU KNOW YOU NAME THE RAY.
WE GET ASKED TO DO IN THE IN
THE EXPRESS THAT. SIR MARCUS
SIR MINDING AND SO BATES THANK
YOU A CHAIRS AND I WANT TO
THANK THE PANEL MA'AM. SOME OF
THESE WILL BE BETTER DIRECTED
TO THE D. BUT THE TAKEAWAY ARE
MESSAGING INCOME CITY. AND IT
SEEMS OF THE MEN ON. NOW WITH
THE- OF THE CROWN VIRUS PEOPLE
ARE CANCELING CONTRACTS. A LOT
OF TRAVELERS TODAY'S. ARREST
SOME ON MINE IT'S LIKE THE
AIRLINES. FOR REST. I'M SURE
BUT SO THERE COULD DRESS LINKS
TO THE DMV. THIS ROOM THERE'S
AN- MAYBE YOU HAVE TO CLICK A
WARNING ABOUT SECURING REAL ID
WILL YOU CAN MAKE YOUR
RESERVATION FOR YOUR NEXT CELL
AND OF THAT SOMETHING THE
AIRLINE COULD UP. ON BUT I'M SO
MESSAGING. AIRPORT CAPACITY SO
I THINK NO MATTER WHAT
MESSAGING GOES THERE'S GONNA BE
A RUSH BEFORE OCTOBER SECOND SO
WHEN WE GET DIEM VIA. WANT TO
QUIT WE HAD DIEM. IN ANTI. BUT
IF THERE IS COOPER WITH AIRPORT
I'M CURIOUS MAYBE MISS MILLER
SEEMS. ASPEN COULD GO THROUGH
THIS IS. KERN WITHOUT NEEDING
REAL ID THEY GET. TSA TO WHERE
THEY'RE AT THE GATES WHERE
THEY'RE WAITING FOR THEIR
FLIGHT SO PEOPLE GET THERE AN
HOUR AT A TIME. TWIN THEY'VE
SOME TIME. THAT KIANA. SAYS GET
YOUR RELY HERE BUT YOU'VE GOT
TO HAVE THE RIGHT ID WITH YOU
TO SIGN UP FOR REAL. I KNOW YOU
PHILIP TATUM MIND BEFORE NGUYEN.
YOU'RE TEAM BE A POINT YOU CAN
FILL OUT SOME OF THE- THAT MAY
FROM OR- WHAT WOULD BE THE BEST.
SAID IN. YOUR IN INCOME. AND
HAD YOU ENVISION ROLE THAT OUT
IN HAD YOU ENVISION BRINGING
THE CORRECT ID WITH ARE THESE
KEY GONNA SIT THE- TWELVE HOUR
DAY OR- WILL PEOPLE UP IN TAKE
ADVANTAGE IT. I THINK IS TWO
STEP PROCESS THE FIRST FOR IT
FOR THE YEAR TO HAVING HIS WITH
OUR T. BANK RIGHT NOW ABOUT LEE.
CAN PASS AS PASSENGERS ARE
GOING THROUGH THE STREETS THIS
CHECK. AB IDENT THE NEED THE
TIME LINE WE NEED TO HAVE IN AS
WELL DOCUMENT JEAN THEY HAVE
WITH YOU IN ORDER TO GET THE ID.
AND AT THE SAID SO IT. AND NOT
ONLY SKAGGS BUT THE DOCUMENT
THAT THAT IS NEEDED. WE WILLING
TO WORK VERY WITH WITH THE DMV
AYE I SEE IT AS AS MORE OF A OF
A- LABOR INTENSIVE ISSUE FOR
THE DMV. BUDGET THOSE PEOPLE IF
WE FOUGHT THE MOP OF MINNESOTA
WITH A VERY GONE TO THE ONLINE
APP. PROCESS TO ENROLL IMAGES
PICKING UP. THEIR CAR. YOU
STILL NEED SOME THERE TO TAKE
PHOTO WE NEED SOMEONE THERE I
CAN PROCESS THAT THE- THAT
PERSON AT ALL IF YOU GONNA BUT
FOR. THAN IS DOING THE WHOLE
THEY HOPEFULLY THEY HAVE ALL OF
THE AND THEY KNOW SO. WHERE
READY TO STEP. AND NEED TO KNOW
WHAT. DO WE HAVE. AT THE YEAR
WE NEED A NEW NET THAT WILL BE
SOLELY FOR THE- YOU KNOW WHAT.
WOULD WE HAVE TO TAKE AN OR-
PULLED WITH. THANK ALSO TAKE A
HARD LOOK IT SHOULD THOSE
PEOPLE THE ARE TRAVELING WE
SOMETHING PRE SECURE THAT
PEOPLE I DO HAVE AN ALTAR SITE
THE I CAN GO I DON'T HAVE TO GO
DMV MAYBE I CAN GO TO THE YEAR.
I HAVE THE SCREENING AND PULLED
PROCESS AS WELL AS QUESTIONS.
FOR SOMEBODY WHO NOT PLANNING
FLIGHT TO GO TO A AIRPORT THERE
LOOK DMV UP. FINAL QUESTION FOR
THE AIRLINE. IN TERMS OF THE
MESSAGING AGAIN. SO YOU BOARD A
FLIGHT THERE'S SOME SAFE
WARNINGS THAT FIGHTING AND RIDE
WITH DURING THE COURSE OF THE-
CAN THEY ALSO. MAKE THE SENATE
TERM AND PASS HAND A FLYER THAT
IS A REMINDER COULD YOU GET
COOPERATION FROM THE AIRLINES
TO HELP WITH MESSAGING.
MENTIONED IN THE AIRLINES ARE
DOING A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
THINGS ALREADY TO COMMUNICATE
THOSE MESSAGES- AND
SPECIFICALLY IN FLIGHT YOUR
POINT- SENATOR IS- THEY HAVE A
NUMBER THEM ALREADY- VIDEOS ON.
THIS IS TOM THE KNOW THEIR
INVITE MATT TEENS A LOT OF
THOSE CAN ARE A ALREADY HALF ON
BOARD THERE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THIRD ON. OKAY
YOU FOR. NO THE LIGHT COMPUTERS
THERE YOU GO THANK YOU ARE I AM
I'M JUST A QUICK STATEMENT I
THINK QUORUM OF THE AGENCY AND
HAVE BEEN A LITTLE. SKEWED OF
TRIED INSURED SAFETY OF OUR OUR
FLYING. INCOME AND THE OF THE
IS NOT REALLY INTERNATIONAL THE
IT'S THE MISSION TSA AND ARE I
BELIEVE WOULD HAVE THE B. THEY
GOT THAT HOLY GOT FOR. SECURING
GETTING MY DOCUMENTS READY
BECAUSE I MARRIED I CHANGED MY
NAME MADE NAME TWO MARRIED NAME
AND I WAS TOLD I NEED IN MY
MARRIAGE. GOOD LUCK ON FINDING
THAT OUT I GUESS THAT'S BEING
CHANGED WITHOUT OUT THERE SO
ENSURING THAT DIEM. TSA ALL OF
THE AIRLINE. HOW YOU LIVE OF
THE DOCUMENTS THAT YOU NEED
JUST FINE EVERY TIME YOU WANT
SOMETHING WITH YOUR LIFE AND
THREE. AIRLINE KICK I THAT'S
THE CORE. OF A LOT EASIER
PEOPLE DOT FROM. OIL DO IT
TOMORROW. THE IS NON ANY WHAT
IS THAT I. DO I DO GO TO THE
COUNTY TO GET MY BURSAR.
MARRIAGE ALL OF THAT AND THAT
WOULD BE HELP AND NOT SYSTEM OF
A STE IN A- BUT I LIKE YOUR-
THIS. FOR WITH A HUNDRED YOU
HAVE. A MERRY. THREE TIMES. AS
YOU CHANGE. THE TIME SINCE
BIRTH WHO WHO ARE YOU REALLY
ARE AN THOSE ARE THE THAT ARE
TO US ASK WORK AS AND DOLLY. I
HAD TO SAY EXPERIENCE HAVING MY
MARRIAGE LIFE TRYING TO GET MY
ID AND IN WASHINGTON BUT BUT IN
RISK TO YOUR CONCERN THIRD.
FROM THE AIR PERSON. AS AMEND
WE'VE BEEN TO OUT THE CORRECT
INFORMATION TO PASSENGERS WHICH
BEAR BY STATE NOT AS- ID I OUR
TEMPS TO COMMUNICATE A STE NINE
MESSAGE. PEOPLE TO BUT- THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE THAT MEDICATION
THAT WE HAVE THAT THIS STATE
STATE. CAN BE EASILY LOW AND
THEN BE THAT I JUST ADD ON
THERE ARE NO OF THAT UNDER WAY
HAVE ONE BILL AND FOR THAT I A
OF. INCOME THE- THING TO PUT
WHOLE PUZZLES. TO LESS BURDEN
ON THE- OBTAIN THEIR REAL ID OF
A FOR OUR FOR THE AIRLINES WE
ARE. OF INITIATIVE THAT WE LET
THAT BIRD IN AS A AS THEY A
PULLED ON THE SECURE AND- I
JUST THINK THAT THERE WAS THE
GENDER BIAS START AND I ALL OF.
WOMEN AGAINST. LEVEL AND NOW IS
VERY DISTURBING KNOWING WHO HAD
OF. DIDN'T YOU THEIR NAME HIGH
I NEEDED WITH THEIR MERRY.
MAYBE THAT HE NEEDED TO WITH
THIS GUY FOR. A THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TO AGAIN JUST ANOTHER NOTE
ARE AGENTS NEED TO DEFY THEIR
CORE MISSIONS. AND I DON'T
THINK WE- SHOULD BE THAT THANK
YOU FOR DODD. THE ROOM. YEAH I
DO TO LOOK AT THE YELP SOMEBODY
THAT I PEOPLE DO CRAP EIGHT I
DON'T KNOW IF WE GET FIVE OH
THAT. IN VERSES WE HAVE EIGHT
EIGHT AND WE NEED TO GET TO
SIXTEEN SO THAT AT MEANS TO ME
THAT WERE PAID THROUGH THEIR
EYES. NOW WHAT THAT INTO. EIGHT
PEOPLE I BLOOD IN THE NEXT.
SEVEN MULTIPLE WILL FIND OUT I
LOVE THIS IDEA ABOUT HAPPY
KIOSKS YOU TEMPORARY IN THE
AIRPORTS JUST A YOU KNOW THIS
ADVICE IS WORTH- ABSOLUTELY
WHAT YOU'RE PAYING ME. NOTHING
WE AS AMERICANS WE IS
CALIFORNIANS ARE ASKED FOR
IDEAS ALL THE TIME. IT'S A
BANKS WHETHER IT'S WHEN I CHECK
INTO A HOTEL- THERE ASK ME
HERE. YEAH THE MID MAYBE EVEN
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY WE
COULD START BE YOU'LL HAVE A
PEOPLE I GOT BACK INTO THE
SHERATON OUTSIDE STAY OVERNIGHT.
YEAH SO I HAVE. BUT HEY- THIS
IS NOT A REAL IDEA YOU NEED IF
YOU'RE GONNA TRAVEL ON PLAYED
YOU'RE GONNA NEED THIS MAY BE A
FIRE YELL COMPANY UP. BANKS
YELLED YOUR IN THE LIFE JUST
FROM A SECURITY STANDPOINT
MAYBE THAT WOULD BE. HELPFUL
YOUR- THE RUBIO THANK YOU-
WHERE IT MY COMMENT IS ALONG
THE LINE OF MISTER DODDS AS
WELL AS MISTER MONEY WHAT I
HEARD AND THE REAL IT'S NOT
REALLY TED. THE WORK OR DO YOU
TO TELL YOU WHAT TO DO WHAT
I'VE NOTICED IS BECAUSE WERE
FREQUENT FLYERS AND- YOU KNOW
YOU. COME ACROSS. PEOPLE WHAT
IS THIS. ALL THAT ALL SAYS THE
ONE THAT. HAS THE I PARTIALS
I'M FOR NEED TO RELY. MHM I'VE
HEARD THE CONVERSE LIKE WHAT IS
THAT IN. AND SO HAVE THE KIDS
THERE WOULD. WOULD BE IN TO SAY
YOU CAN GET IT RIGHT NOW RIGHT.
THIS ONE ARE THE THAT IT'S WHAT
MR DOT IS A LEADING TO LIKE
HAVING. SORT OF COLLAPSE. I IN
OUR BE TIME I GALLON FOR SHE
WOULD ALWAYS SAY YEAH DON'T
FORGET IT'S NOT NOT EVERYONE
DOES IT AND I'M OF YOU CAN
ENCOURAGE ALL YOU YOU KNOW THE
TSA WORKERS TO TELL KEEP DURING
NOW. I THINK FAR. BACK YOU KNOW
MAN I ONE BUT DOES IT ALL THE
TIME. YOU WANT TO SENATE. THE
AHA MOMENTS FOR MANY PEOPLE
THAT KNOW WHAT IT. ES JUST MAKE
THINKING VERY OTHER QUESTIONS
FURTHER SIR OF. JUST A I WANT
TO RUN OVER THE- FUNDING. THE
REAL LIFE WE STARTED FINDING IT
AND- THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FISCAL YEAR. AND IT
WAS A VERY MODEST FORM HAVE
MILLION DOLLARS- THAT IT WENT
UP TO TWENTY THREE MILLION AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
TWENTY NINETY NINE. EIGHTY NINE
IT WAS AT THE HUNTER NINE POINT
SIX MILLION TWENTY. NINETEEN
TWENTY IT WENT UP TO LEARN
FORTY TWO POINT TWO. MILLION
AND A THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. AND I WENT
FROM SEVEN POSITIONS ADDED. IN
FIVE YEARS AGO AS CENTURY WHEN
WE START ALLOCATING MONEY FOR
REAL ID. IT WAS SEVENTY
PRESERVE OUR AT. YEAH SURE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTY TWO ADDED
POSITIONS. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT GIVES YOU AN
IDEA OF. HOW. THE THING
BLOSSOMED- PROBABLY AND- TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN THEY ACTUALLY
STARTED ISSUING. THE REAL I DIS
IS WHEN WE REALLY ADDED. YOU
KNOW TWELVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES.
OKAY SO WE- SO NOW I THINK
THANK YOU PANEL AND- WELL NO
TURN TO OUR DIRECTOR MISTER
GORDON. AND HE'S GOING TO GIVE
US SO. GOOD THE WELL HE'S GOING
TO GIVE US AN UPDATE- AND I
WANTED TO DO THAT IN TERMS OF
THE SAID WAY TO HIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME SO- WILL
NOW TURN TO MISTER GORDON OR
DIRECTOR OF THE PARMA MOTOR
VEHICLES AND- SO YOU MISTER
GORE IN JULY. THE START OF HIS
JOB IS DIRECTORS A NEW DIRECTOR
IN JULY LAST YEAR. AND HE'S
BEEN ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN ALL
THESE ISSUES AND ALL ALL TURNED
IT OVER TO MISTER GORDON SO HE
CAN MAKE HIS PRESENTATION AT
THIS TIME. YEAH THANK YOU. ARE
WE ON YES AGO YOUR GO AND TEST
GREAT GOOD MORNING CHAIRS AND
SENATORS- I'M STEEP GARDEN AS
US INVOLVEMENT AND REPORTER
MICHAEL CLOSER HAPPY TO DO
THAT- I'M SECORD ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
MOTOR VEHICLES I SPENT MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR DATA AND
TECHNOLOGY TO IMPROVE COMPANY
AND AS MUCH THANKS. THAT IS.
SURE THE GOVERNORS AND THE
SECTORS COMMITTED TO MODERNIZE
THE DMV A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
DMV NEED TO HAD. SOMERS THE
FLEXIBILITY COMPLETE THE BILL
VIA THE PREFERRED METHOD.
WHETHER THAT TECH CALL IT CHAO.
EXPERIENCE THERE ARE MUCH OF AN
EFFICIENT AFFECT INTUITIVE
BECAUSE SERVICE EXPERIENCE
MATTER THE SERVICE CHANNEL.
THIS IS MY LONG TERM VISION FOR
THE DMV BUT TODAY I THINK IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED BY THE PREVIOUS-
SPEAKERS THAT WE FACE URGENT
SITUATION. REALLY IT'S
PRESENTED THE DMV WITH AN
UNPRECEDENTED AND STORE
CHALLENGED ME TO CALIFORNIA HAS
COME INTO A DMV FIELD OFFICE
AND REQUEST A FEDERALLY. NINE
REAL ID. FOR THE- FIRST. SET OF
DOCUMENTS AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM.
THIS IS IMPORTANT REMEMBER THE
CALIFORNIA IS A VOLUNTARY
STATE. CALIFORNIA IS NOT
MANDATING FOR NEEDS TO GET REAL
ID'S. BASED ON OUR SURVEY
ABOUT. STEVIE ASSUMED A
PARTICIPATION RATE OF ABOUT 75%
WHICH REPRESENTS THE SIXTEEN
MENTION SIXTY MILLION POTENTIAL
CUSTOMERS. GEN PREVIOUSLY. WE
ANTICIPATED A LOWER PER SPACE
RATE AT THE ONSET AS YOU WOULD
WITH ANY NEW PROGRAM AND WE
EXPECT AS THE OCTOBER
ENFORCEMENT DATE APPROACHES. AS
DISCUSSED. GONNA GET THIS YEAR.
FAR POSSIBLY SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION FOR HIS HAVE A REAL ID
TOTAL PARTICIPATION RATE HAS
BEEN LOWER THAN EXPECTED. WE
HAVE PARTICIPATION PERCENTAGE
INCREASES EACH MONTH A GIVEN
THE CURRENT AND IT'S ON THE
THAT THE SIXTEEN BECAUSE ACOSTA
REAL ID BETWEEN NOW. FIRST NEED
ONE. THREE CLICK IT IS. AS WE
MOVE SIR WE DO I'M SORRY THE
DOESN'T EIGHT WILL INCREASE AS
WE MOVE CLOSER TO REAL IDEA A
AND WE EXPECT TRACTOR DURING
THE SUMMER ALL. INCREASED HEART
APARTMENTS ENCOURAGE RESIDENTS
TO COME THE FIELD UP TO WHAT
THE THAN WAITING FOR THE IN
DATE. WE ARE INCREASING
CAPACITIES WE CAN PROVIDE MORE
WE- IN TWO MONTHS. THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO LINE A MULTI
STATEWIDE PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS TO. THREE
FRONTS ONE IS TO HELP
CALIFORNIA'S DETERMINES WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WANT A REAL ID OR
NOT. SECOND ONE TO DO WHAT
MAKES COMING PREPARED AND THIRD
ROSSUM CRAZY BUT A COMMON NOW
WE WANT TO THAT. THOUGH AS THIS
MAY GENERATE IT SHOWS UP ON.
THE THIRTIETH WILL BE UNTENABLE
SITUATION. BACK PAIN. WEBSITE
HAS REALLY INCREASED REAL ID
AWARENESS AND THOSE A COMMON
ARE MORE PREPARED AND DON'T
HAVE TO COME BACK FOR A SECOND
WHICH IS VERY. RESTED FROM.
DEPARTMENTS TRANSACTION TIME TO
SERVE COSTA THIRD MORE
CUSTOMERS DURING THE
EXAMINATION OF OUR PROCESS
CONSULTANTS MCKINSEY COMPANY
DETERMINE THAT IT TOOK TWENTY
EIGHT MINUTES TO PROCESS A REAL
ID. THIS SIMPLIFY THE REAL ID
PROP. APPS INSURING THE
CUSTOMERS ARE PREPARED ANY
OFFICE VISIT AND STARTING THIS
MONTH WE ARE EXPECTING TO SEE
THE AVERAGE RELATED HAS REDUCED
BY OVER 50% IN FIVE FIELD
OFFICE TO OUR STATE CUSTOMERS-
RECEIVE EVEN FASTER SERVICES
PART OF THE PROJECT AND TO
UPLOAD THE DOCUMENTS IN ADVANCE.
WE ALL ARE SPENDING EIGHTEEN
OFFICES THAT ACTUALLY STARTED
ON MONDAY OF THIS. I AND WE
EXPECT TO ROLL OUT STATEWIDE BY
SUMMER IT INNOVATIONS LIKE VISA
A REDUCED. I'VE OUR WAIT TIME
DOWN. BUT OUR AVERAGE TIMES
EVERY MAY BUT LAURA OF AND I
FOR NOT A PLAN BECAUSE MY EVE
AS A NUMBER OF THE OFFICE
VISITS CONTINUES TO IT. TAKE
SINCE. MOTOR VEHICLE RIGHT AND
NOT AS ACTION TO ALTER SO
CUSTOMERS. HAVE ACCESS TO
SERVICES WITH OBVIOUS VISIT A
FIELD OFFICE THIS INCLUDES HIGH
VOLUME TRANSACTIONS THAT ARE
BEING MADE POSSIBLE BY THESE
WEBSITE THIRTEEN YEARS OF
EXISTING THIS PART IN OUR WHICH
INCLUDES MORE. STRIP EIGHT. OF
COURSE THE A FOR ME THAT WERE
TODAY. ALL OF THE WILL BE ABLE
A LOT OF THE OFFICE SO CAN
ACTUALLY SERVICE THAT HAVE A
REAL ID THAT HAVE REAL ID READ.
BY REDUCING ABOUT A NON RELATED
DEATHS. WERE CREATED. ATTY AS I
MENTIONED FOR REALITY CUSTOMERS
WHO MUST COME INTO A FIELD
OFFICE. IT IS DEVELOPING A LIST
OF ADDITIONAL STRESS. COULD BE
DEPLOYED IN THE FIELD IF WE SEE
A SIGNIFICANT SPIKE IN COST
DEMAND. TURNED INTO TRIAGE
CUSTOMER SUCH AS- I'VE FEDERAL
COMPLAINT DOCUMENTS TO
APPOINTED BEYOND THE
ENFORCEMENT DAY SIMPLY MOVING
THEM OUT OF THE WAY. OF OTHER
CUSTOMERS MAY. NEED WE MUST
MEET IS ON PRESS. AND MR
CHALLENGE TOGETHER YOUR SUPPORT
DURING LAST YEAR'S BY BLOOD.
STOP HIRED IMPROVED. IN
POSSIBLE ARE LIKE OUR CAMPAIGN.
NEEDED I'D MARK. I APPRECIATE
YOUR BEER TODAY AND FOR YOUR
CONTINUE SUPPORT THANK YOU AND
I PREPARED AN ANY YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU. AWFUL AT. EMPLOYED
STARTING. OUR WHEN WE START
ISSUING- THE REPLY TO IN
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHT THAT'S
CORRECT DAY CORRECT I THOUGHT
HE WAS LIKE IT WAS GIVEN.
MIDDLE HELLO. AS I GET YEAH GEN
AND EVERYONE OKAY SO IF WE- IF
WE PURSUE THE- FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND A FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND A MONTH CLIP. FROM
THEN WE WILL THEN OKAY BUT- IN
ESSENCE WE DID HIT THE-
400-500-1000 TWO. THIS LAST
YEAR CORRECT IT WAS A IT WAS
LATE LAST YEAR THAT WE HAVE
THAT NUMBER SIR. SO WE KIND OF
A- RIGHT NOW WE'RE- THE CLIP
RIGHT NOW WE'RE DOING ABOUT
THAT. BUT WE- ARE. ARE TROUBLED
BY WE HAVE TO MAKE UP FOR PAST
DEFICIENCIES. I YES ESSENTIALLY
SO. HOW WHAT IS YOUR IDEAS
ABOUT HOW TO MAKE YOU KNOW IF
YOU IF YOU IF YOU HAVE THE FULL.
TIME THE SAME RATE YOU WOULD
HAVE BEEN OKAY. BUT IF WHAT
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN TO MAKE UP
THE DEFICIENCIES. IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY AS
WE HEARD EARLIER TO THE
DEFICIENCY WHAT IT BUT IT WILL
HAPPEN. AND HOW OF IT CAN YOU
REALISTICALLY. GO UP AS A AS A
MISSION OPENING REMARKS SENATOR
THAT WITH THE PLAN RIGHT NOW TO
INCREASE THAT TO THE CELL THE
HAS BEEN SAID THAT YOU GUYS
HAVE MADE IN THE DMV. HAS BEEN.
BASS WE IN AS YOU MENTIONED
WORKING WITH OUR BUSINESS
PARTNERS WERE WORKING WITH THE
PUBLIC WE'RE DOING PRESS WERE
DOING ITS BODY BUT IT TALK TO A
SIMMER DOWN AT LA ACTS- LAST
MONTH THE TSA IN THE CA. TRYING
TO GET. SPRING TO THE WAY.
NEVER BEEN LOWER AT THE DMV
ANIMATION WE DON'T WANT. ZERO
THE GOAL IS TO BE ABLE TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE TO GET INTO THE
OFFICE AND ESPECIALLY FOR REAL
ID CONVINCE PEOPLE TO COME AND
PREPARE TO WE'RE TRYING TO NOW
DANGLE. THE CARROT TO BE
ADMITTED IN THIS TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
UPLOAD DOCUMENTS AND THE THING
THEY WERE STARTING TO THE
PROPER TYPE NOW IS WE'RE GONNA
MAKE SURE THAT THAT. DID YOU
WANT TO TALK TO PREFIX. THIS IS
THE WAY WE'RE GOING TO YOU.
THAT WE'VE CREATED IN THE DMV
OFFICE. THE GONNA CREE IN A
TENT FOR YOU SEE THESE ALL THE
TIME WHEN YOU'RE SHOPPING FOR
SOMETHING ONLINE. YOU KNOW
LIMITED SUPPLY WON'T LOOK LONG
CREATED SOME SCARCITY COULD WE
SEE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY. STOP THE APPLE TO
PROP FOR RELIED. THEN YOU. I
DID YOU THE PROCESS AND OUT.
SEE IF EXISTING APPOINTMENT
DREADED SHE IS ALL THAT'S A
AMONG. OR TWO MONTHS OUT. AND
SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
NOW TO INCENTIVIZE THEM SAY
LOOK IF YOU START THIS PROCESS
AND COMPLETE THIS PROCESS.
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A SAME
DAY APPOINTMENT. YOU ARE SO
AGAIN CREEK. URGENCY TO GET
PEOPLE TO START THE PROCESS GET
THEM THROUGH THE PROCESS. AND
GETTING INTO THE OFFICE NOW.
WHY THINGS ARE NOT AS BUSY AS
WE EXT. YOU THINK THAT WOULD
INCREASE EFFICIENCY IN THE
RITUALS ARE TO. FLEE NUMBERS
START TO GO UP. YES AND I THINK
WE SEE REALLY GOOD TRACTION ON
THE WEBSITE AND NEVER PULL. YOU
COME. PER SIDE. OF MY- VERY
FOCUSED MINUTES FULL FOCUS BUT
THESE. THE LADY THAT DMB. EIGHT
I. QUORUM AND THAT'S THE- THAT
ARE TAKEN DIRECTLY FROM. HOME
TO CURE SO THAT. EXPLICIT WITH
ISRAEL ARE WE ALSO HAVE A NAME
CHANGE WIZARD- THAT WE SAW
ACTUALLY AND I DID WAS IN
VIRGINIA. IT'S FANTASTIC WE'VE-
I. CITY PAGES NOT THE LIFE TO
HELP IN SOME OF THAT PROCESS WE
THINK IF WE HAVE ENOUGH THAT
ARE COMING TO THE SITE TODAY TO
HAVE ENOUGH DEMAND WE NEED TO
BE TO DO THIS AT IN THE STORE.
IF YOU WILL. USE IT. SHOPPING
FOR A- PUTS UP A SHOT. IF YOU
THE CHECK OUT I KNOW PEOPLE ARE
STARTING UP A BUT THEY'RE NOT
IT'S OR START PUTTING
INCENTIVES PLACE FOR THE NOPE
THAT AND THAT DEMAND ALONE I
THINK IT IS APPROACH AND UNITS.
SO GOOD EVENING. A 50% UP TO ON
THAT YOU. THAT WHAT DOUBLE OUR
REAL ID THE- WILL NOT DO. ONLY
THAT BUT AS ONE OF MANY STRAY.
WORK AND I TRY TO GET MORE.
JUST THE PROCESS INCREASE
INCENTIVE THE COUPLE. GET INTO.
OFFICE OKAY SO WHAT. GOOD THE
PROBLEM ISN'T THE WAY TIMES IS
AS DECK IS GETTING PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
AT THIS POINT AND INCENTIVIZING
THEM TO COME IN NOW RATHER THAN
WAIT AS ROCK WAS BUT I THINK
THERE IS OUT. SECTION THAT
WE'VE BUILT OVER MANY MANY
YEARS OF THE- IN APPOINTMENT TO
DO ANYTHING AN HOUR TRYING TO
DISABUSE PEOPLE THAT NOTION
IT'S VERY HARD TO CHANGE
PEOPLE'S MINDS. WE'RE NOW
TRYING TO. AND WE GOT. VERSION
OF IT IN UPON WHICH WE- TAKE
THAT ONE OBSTACLE OUT OF THE
WAY IT WILL BE TESTING THAT
FEEL LATER THIS MONTH WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE THE START PROMOTE.
REAL TIME IT WE'RE GOING TO GET
THE LOOKING FOR OVERTIME. YOU
ARE STARTING FORM THEY'RE
COMING TO THE PAGE THERE
SHOWING INTEREST AND CURIOSITY
BUT THEY'RE NOT IF YOU ARE NOT
PUNCHING IT. AND WE BELIEVE IN
THE FEEDBACK. IS THAT THEY GET
TO. ROSS START LOOKING AT THE
POINT ACCOUNT IS A- THAT'S A
COUPLE MONTHS NOW. IT IS GOING
TO GIVE UP THEIR GONNA IF YOU
ABANDON THE SHOPPING CART SO
WE'RE GONNA GET TRY TO LOOK
PROCESS BUT TIGHTLY TO GET
PEOPLE INTO THE OFFICE AND- WE
WILL. HAS CHANGED. IF YOU. THE
SIR PARTS. TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY IS TALKED ABOUT IN THE
LAST PANEL. UP THERE WOULD BE
AN INCENTIVE FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO PARTICIPATE AND
MARKETING YOUR- NEW PROCESS
IT'S- USING THE TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGY WITH SIX BY THE
GOVERNOR FIRST PLACE IS I POINT
OUT OF HOW HOW DO YOU. PARTNER
WITH THEM TO THE NEW TECHNOLOGY
THE LAB AT THE DMV TO HELP US
GET THROUGH THIS PROBLEM SO IT
AS A MINIMAL EFFECT ON THE
CALIFORNIA. I HAD TO DO THAT SO
REACH OUT TO ALL THE AIRLINES%
DIRECTLY TO REACH OUT TO THE
AIRPORT COUNCIL THAT IS THE
REPRESENTATIVE AS WELL
CONSTITUENTS AT THE- HE- TO
BOTH YOU. JOINT MARKETING
PROGRAMS AS YOU MENTION. THAT
VIDEO BILL THAT'S PLAN IN
VARIOUS AIRPORTS THAT SOURCE
FROM THE DMV FLY THROUGH SMF
APERTURE AS MANY OF YOU DO.
THAT VIDEO JUST ABOUT SECURITY
THAT'S ALL PRODUCTS WERE. THE
VERY TERRIBLE SUMMIT AND MUCH
MORE COOPER BURBANK ONE. OTHERS
HAVE BEEN LESS UP LATE SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO DRIVE MATERIAL
INTO THE INTO THEIR
ENVIRONMENT. I THINK THE REAL
OPPORTUNITIES I THINK WAS WAS
STATED- BY- BY FRENCH FOR THE
BURKE. IS NOW PUTTING BE IN A
MORE MOLD. SO WE ARE IN THE
POWER. MR MILLER THANK YOU. I'M
I'M MY NAME SIR NOT AS GOOD AS
IT BE BANNED. MR MILLER RIGHT.
IN BEING ABLE TO ABLE TO A
MOBILE OPPORTUNITY GET MORE
CUSTOMERS ARE BUT I THINK. ALSO
WRITTEN. DMV TO YOU THERE BEEN
NEAR TEN THOUSAND OR O- RE
IDEAS THAT HAVE BEEN ISSUED
THROUGH THAT PROCESS. NOT NOT A
NOT A HUNDRED THOUSAND MILLION.
IT'S SIGNIFICAN IN GOING OUT
TWO. IN HELPING EMPLOYERS AND
HAVE A OP EMPLOYEES A TRAVEL
FREQUENTLY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BE BENEATH. YEAH PROGRAM IS IT
SAYS ONE. AND IS FULL. INTO THE
CAN OFFICE. OF THE THREE
STRATEGIES TO GET BEYOND BEING
MORE. AT THE AIRPORT MORE WORK
OF A LIGHT MOBILE SUIT AS WE-
DO YOU A- STRATEGY. WITH YOU
KNOW 50% REDUCTION IN IS
SIGNIFICANT AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE
AVERAGING JUST ABOUT TEN
MINUTES YOU TAKE WE TAKEN FROM
TWENTY MINUTES TO TEN THAT
SIGNATURE ATHLETE END OF THE
THREE ABOUT IS THE ECONOMIC
VALUE TO CAL. EIGHTEEN THERE US.
INTO THE- YOU IT DOES DOES OF
THE PROCESSES WOULD BE
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT DURING
THIS SITUATION THAT WE HAVE
FROM A HEALTH STANDPOINT WITH
THE- BYRON VIRUSES RESTRICTIONS
ON ON. PEOPLE GATHERING AND
LARGE LOCATIONS LIKE THE DMV AT
IS THE DMV- STUDYING.
RESTRICTIONS ON VISITING TO THE
OFFICE SO INTENTIONAL LAST
QUESTION FIRST- NO RESTRICTIONS
IN PLACE TODAY VISITING A DMV
OFFICE PEOPLE HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERN AND WE ARE FOLLOWING
ALL ALL THE HEALTH PLANS BUT
THE OPPORTUNITY IS YEAH WE GET
INTO THIS MESS WHERE THERE ARE
A LARGE CON. ANY AGAIN MY- THE-
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
TRAVELING AND GOING TO PLACES
WERE LARGE AMOUNTS OF PEOPLE
NOT. I'M THAT WOULD HAS IT THE
HESITATION TO. GO TO THE DMV
OFFICE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT COULD
BE WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
DAMPENING OF TRAFFIC INTO THE
DMV OFFICES BUT I SUSPECT THAT
THIS. CRISIS EVOLVES PEEPER BUT
IF YOU'RE A BACK BACK TO YOUR
PREVIOUS QUESTION ABOUT SORT OF
LARGE POPULATIONS OF PEOPLE TO
ONE YOUR POINT BOB DONNAN TURN
OF. WHERE PEOPLE CAN BE CAUGHT
ARE ARE OPEN INSIDE THE
SIGNIFICANT AIRPORTS WHERE
THERE ARE LARGE CONCENTRATIONS
OF THE TRAVELING PUBLIC. IF
THOSE ARE INSIGNIFICANT AT
NUMBERS WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
HE'LL BE ABLE GET YOUR- I JUST
DO ONE A DAY WE WANT TO BE DO.
HOUSE INCIDENT. THE TRAFFIC
THAT IT CAN BE VERY AND- IN AN
ARBOR TO ATTRACT WE ALSO BEEN
DISCUSSING WITH SPORTS TEAMS
AND SO ON. SO BE IT A SPORT.
SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS ARE. FORTY
NINE IN YOUR BACKYARD COULD GO
TO A PLACE WHERE THERE ARE
LARGE CONCENTRATIONS PEOPLE BUT
THEM THE VIRUS OF COURSE WAS
PUT THOSE LARGE CONCENTRATIONS
BE COUNTY ADDRESS. TO THE- YEAH.
YES AS I WRITE. EXT THE DAY
THE- ADDRESS. OKAY OF I THINK
CENTER MORE LARK AND- SIR DOLLY
OKAY SIR MODOC BURDEN YOU'RE
NEW TO THE DEPARTMENT I CAN'T.
ASK OKAY QUESTION. IT IS IT IS
AND I I'M JUST CURIOUS I HAD A
COMPLAINT JUST YESTERDAY AND
MAYBE SO NUMBER CAN ANSWER THIS
ONE BUT A GENTLEMAN WHEN IN THE
DO YOU. OF ALL. HIS MILITARY ID
WHICH SHOULD INDICATE THAT HE'S
ALREADY SHOWN APPROVED A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE ALL THE OTHER
REQUIREMENTS. YEAH HEFELT THAT
THAT WAS SATISFACTORY
SUBSTITUTE BUT HE WAS DECLINED
AND IT'S FOR THE APPOINTMENT
DID I'M JUST WONDERING WHY-
CERTAIN. FEDERAL DOCUMENTS
WOULDN'T BE RECOGNIZED IN THE
PROCESS OF MAKING SHOULD BACK
UP. CERTAIN EVIDENCE OF ALREADY
SHOWN SHOWN SOMEONE TO GET THE
ARE THAT YOU QUALIFY THAT THAT
THAT'S RIGHT I DON'T KNOW THE
PARTICULARS OF THE SITUATION WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO THIS
CONSTITUENTS. THE THEN THE NET
OF IT IS THERE ARE SOME
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE DEFINED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
FOLLOW THOSE TO THE LETTER SO
WE DO NOT GET REAL ID'S INVALID
IN THE CITY YEAH. A VERY
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
THE SONS AS OUR BROAD RANGE OF
DOCTORS BUT THOSE ARE THE THOSE
ARE THE IDENTITY DOCUMENTS AND
THAT'S REALLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT WE HAVE TO
DO. SO COULD BE THAT THERE ARE
OTHER WHEN SUCH AS WERE IT UP.
SO OFTEN ALSO SHOULD BE THAT.
COP HIM TO SEND SOME OUT SEND
THEM BACK TO OFTEN GET MORE
DOCUMENT. BUT THE IMPORT OF
THIS. ONLINE SOME WORK ON A DMV
EXPRESSED BUT THAT ON THE
SYSTEM. DEVELOP A- PREACHER.
THIS IS AN- LOAD. AS THE FOR
DOCTOR THAT ARE. IT WOULD TELL
YOU WHETHER NOT THOSE MATCH THE
MINIMUM CRITERIA TO GET A
REALITY. OUR HOPE IT BE ABLE TO
DE RISK IT FROM THE-
PERSPECTIVE SO HELPING
SUCCESSFUL. AND LESS STRESS
BECAUSE NOW THEY KNOW RIGHT NOW
PEOPLE COME IN. WHAT IS OF SOME
AND WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THEY HAVE. AND HE WOULD BE
IF WE CAN. THIS IS A BEEN TODAY
IN THE IN. STAGE IT WILL MAKE
THEM FEEL BETTER NO FEEL MORE
CONFIDENT THAT THEY HAVE
UPLOADED THE RIGHT DOCUMENTS BE
VALIDATED IN ADVANCE THEY'LL
BRING THE SAME DOCUMENTS IN AND
THE SITUATION SCHOOL REBEL
RELATIVE QUICKLY AS A PROPER
THEM FOR THIS COMES TO. YOU HAD
A- PREDICT IN CITY. THE ONLY.
TO THE TWENTY THIRD THIS WEEK.
STATEWIDE AGAIN OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE BUT HOPEFULLY WE'LL SEE
A REDUCTION IN THOSE TYPE OF
ACTIVITIES AS WE PROMOTE- THE
SYSTEM STATEWIDE. THEN WHEN YOU
ALLOWED DMV RENEWALS ARE YOU
INCLUDING AN INSERT ON REAL ID.
WE ARE THERE IS A BOTH A
INSERTS AND PRINTED MATERIALS
BUT FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE
OPEN TO DIEM RENEWALS AND
THERE'S A LOT. OF IN THERE AND
WE'RE TO. AT SEND THE RIGHT
MESSAGE WITHOUT. CLOUDING
MESSES WITH OTHER MATERIALS SO
CS ARE ANSWERED YES THERE ARE
THINGS I'M PRETTY MATURE ALL.
AND IT'S ACROSS ALMOST ALL OF
OUR DOCTORS VEHICLE
REGISTRATION AS WELL AS
IDENTIFICATION. WHEN SOMEONE
GOES ON TO. WRITE TO REGISTER.
ALSO GET THE QUESTION ARE YOU
MISTER DEVOTE. AND WE'VE
ALREADY A HEARING ON THE
MATTER- BUT ARE YOU ALSO.
ASKING THE QUESTION ARE YOU DO
YOU HAVE REAL ID OR- DOES IT
SAY HEY THANK YOU VERY GOT REAL
ID GOOD JOB TWO THUMBS UP. WELL
I. DO THAT TWO THUMBS UP BUT WE
DO. DIRECT PEOPLE TO THIS REPLY
DECIDED WAS TALK ABOUT. HE SAID
WHEN YOU START THE APPLICATION
PROCESS THE ASSUMPTION IS POINT
IN A MAYBE WE SHOULD MAYBE
SHOULD BE MAKING THE SUBJECT
SUB ON AND THAT PEOPLE KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE A CARD
WE GIVE THEM THE STEPS TO.
FIGHT WITH IT. BUT WITH THE
STOP. TO BE ENCOURAGED GET A
REALITY. SO WHEN THEY START THE
PROCESS. YOU KNOW THAT WHEN
THEY WHEN THEY ACTUALLY START
THE APPLICATION ONLINE. THE
ASSUMPTION WERE MAKING THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE NOT EVER
REALIZE YOU'RE NOT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU JEFF THANK YOU FOR
VIOLENCE ARE ABOVE. THANK YOU
THE DIRECTOR GORE 9% YOU BEING
HERE. CENTER MORE LIKE ASKED IF
YOU THE QUESTIONS I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT I HAVE-
MAYBE LITTLE TWIST HERE ONE IS.
GIVING OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN
SO WE YOU KNOW WE'VE ACTUALLY
FIRST BALK CITED HERE THE HOW
MY REAL IDEA. BECAUSE I HAVE.
SECURE ALL THE INFORMATION I
NEED TO GO TO THE- DMV WHICH
I'LL BE DOING HERE SHORTLY SO
I'M HOPING MY EXPERIENCES
TENANTS I'VE NEVER BEEN TO THE
DMV. UNDER A HALF HOUR OF MY
LIFE SO I'M GONNA ACTUALLY
GUILTY I IT SEE HOW. WELL WERE.
I'M WE'VE WE'VE BEEN FUSED TO
LEARN. ACCORDING TO THE
INFORMATION I HAVE HERE ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET WHICH IS
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
POINT EIGHT NEW PERMANENT
POSITION SINCE. AND THEN A
CONTINUE OF NINE HUNDRED-
TEMPORARY POSITIONS SO THAT
SOME. IS DRY AND- THAT WAY TIME
WE HAVE MORE. ARE SAYS IT. AND
THEN ALSO. IN HERE THAT WE CAN
ALL. SO IT PASSED THE TEAM NOT.
THAT TIME THE UPGRADES A DID
ONE. VERY GOOD UPGRADE IN
ACTUALLY. MADE THE SYSTEM NOT
WORK AS WELL- SO IN YOUR
TECHNOLOGY UPGRADES CAN YOU
GIVE ME. BACKGROUND YOU
ACTUALLY DID AND- AND I WANT
YOU TO TOUCH ON IT BEING
SECURE- YOU KNOW YOUR- CARD
INFORMATION. TAKING DEBIT CARD
FOR. YOU ARE TAKING ALL OF
INFORMATION NOW BIRTH
CERTIFICATES AND THE LIKES HOW
HOW'S THAT INFORMATION SECURE
THAT IS REALLY PERSON
INFORMATION TO SOMEBODY'S
PERSONAL LIFE APSO GOOD SET OF
QUESTIONS THERE. PROCESS I
MENTIONED YOU REDUCING THE
CYCLE TIME IF YOU WILL FROM
TWENTY EIGHT TO TEN AS WE
EXPECTED SCALED SO THAT. KIND
OF. THREE ARE PERCENT
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY IS JUST THE
WAY BODIES AT IT WE'RE HAVING
MAKE MAKING SURE THE PEOPLE
ARE. ARE DOING WORKS. GOING BE
BLOOD. WE THAT THAT YEAH I'M
WITH YOU ON THAT SO ON THE
TECHNOLOGY FRONT I MEAN WE ARE
USING THINGS THAT THAT ARE
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW TIED IN THIS
STANDARD. WITH THE- SPANISH FOR
INFORMATION. MAKING SURE THAT
SUMMIT. BUT A DOCUMENT. IT SURE
THAT IT. YEP CITY TRAGIC. WE
SHOULD BE ENCRYPTED PRESIDENT
OF THE WERE FINE ALTHOUGH
STANDARDS TO ME THE PEOPLE'S
INFORMATION STATE. THERE'S
ALWAYS A RISK EVERY YOU.
DOCTRINE INTO AND I CARE IN
YOUR CAR WHATEVER. WAS REST WE
ARE TAKING ALL THE PRUDENT. AND
FEDERAL DEFINED STANDARDS
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE RIGHT
THING TO DO WE WANT TO. KEEP
INFORMATION STAYS SAFE AND
CALIFORNIA'S BECAUSE- THEY
TRUST GOVERNMENT. YEAH TRY TO
SECURE ON SOME OF FOR P. I.
PERSPECTIVE WE WE'VE ALSO. THE
COME STANDARD WHERE. ANY I AM.
WITH RESPECT TO. YEAH THE
WHERE. ARE OUR APPLE IS WE-
HAVE TO FILL OUT OKAY BUT WHEN
YOU USE YOUR- CARD DIRECT OUT
TO THE CREDIT CARD VENDORS SITE.
SO THAT INFORMATION DOES NOT
CITY THE DMB AT ALL WE HAVE NO
ABILITY. TO YOUR CARD
INFORMATION SO WE REDUCE THAT
RISK. WORKING PROFESSIONALS
VERY FOCUSED AND THE WIND IS.
NOW BACK TO DO OUT. TECHNOLOGY
IS CHALLENGING ABSOLUTELY.
NUMBER THINGS IT. STAND I MEAN
TO IMPROVE OUR OUR FRONT INSIST
MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH THAT TERM
TIP TIP TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
FACT WE CAN HAVE SUPPORT
ABILITY THE SYSTEMS ARE
UPGRADED SURE THAT THEY WILL
OUR FAULT TOLERANT AND THERE
ARE CURRENTLY SUPPORT PLATFORMS.
NUMBER THIS IS A OUR NETWORK WE
HAVE GONE FROM A LITTLE BURKE-
VERY DATED DMV VERY WELL RISE
IN WE SWITCH TO AN OFF BURKE
OUT OVER COMCAST WERE TEN SITES.
ANOTHER SEVEN. AGO BUT WE ARE
ACTIVE WELL IN TIED TO PROCEED.
OF COURSE BACK. A THOSE SITES
BUT ALSO. AS WELL BUT IT WOULD
APPROVED THING IN THE RIGHT OUR-
APPROACHES BROUGHT HIS NEW
SOLUTIONS HAVE TECHNOLOGY
BACKGROUND BUT ALSO SOME OF MY
SEE LEADERS HAVE. BACKGROUND AS
WELL TRYING TO MAKE SMART MAKE
SURE THEY FIT A- SURE THERE.
AND THAT FOR EXAMPLE WITH CALM
LOSING IT. MULTIPLE LEVELS RE.
SO IF THE PRIMER LINK FAIL WE
HAVE A BACK UP EVEN A CHURCH
SOLUTION SO WE ARE IN TRYING TO
BE. WITH THE TAX BERMAN I AM A
TAXPAYER TOO- AND WHICH- THIS
THIS FIVE SUPPORTER NEEDS. SO
ARE. WE HAVE A- THAT DATA BEING
COLLECTED YOU KNOW THEN THE
PASTOR WAS THE- THEY WERE
SELLING FAKE. A CLASS ONE
LICENSES SO I MEAN THAT THAT
INFORMATION THAT IS BEING
GATHERED IS HOW ARE YOU DOING
ANYTHING TO LIKES MAKE SURE
THAT YOUR EMPLOYEES ARE SECURE
THAT THEY THEY THEY CAN'T TAKE
MY PERSONAL INFORMATION THAT
I'M REQUIRED TO SUBMIT TO GET A
REAL ID ND USE IT FOR SOME
OTHER PURPOSE IS THERE ANY LIKE.
DELETED DOUBLE CHECK OR TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
NOBODY TAKE THAT INFORMATION
BECAUSE I KNOW IN THE PAST-
THERE WERE SOME PEOPLE THAT
WERE ACTUALLY WORK. AB THAT
WERE SELLING. A COMMERCIAL
LICENSES. YOU NEED TO TEST SO
IS THERE A IS THERE ANYBODY
CHECKING ON THAT- YEAH WE'RE
CHECKING ON THE OF THOSE FRONT
I THINK THAT THE- BRIEF. AND
GIVEN THAT A CAME IN ON. THAT
ARE CAUGHT IS HE DOING EXTRA
MONEY. WATCH KEYSTROKE BY EVERY.
WHO IS ACCESSING WHAT. THE
LOOKING AT TIME OF THE
TRANSACTION AND THEY CAN
DETERMINE IF SOMEBODY IS.
EXPEDITED PROCESS SO DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING
THE STEPS THAT ARE REQUIRED.
IT'S TOO SHORT IT GETS
TRIGGERED. FOR INVESTIGATION
DETERMINED. IF SOMEBODY A
PARTICULAR OFFICE MAY BE
CHEATING ON ON A COMMERCIAL
DRIVER'S EXAM AS YOU AS YOU
MENTIONED. AS YOU SEEN MANY OF
THOSE ARE OF THE PEOPLE. SAID
THAT THAT'S ABOUT. AS
TECHNICIANS TEAM. AND THEN BE
THE BEEN USING THIS PROCESS SO
WE HAVE A HALF. BROKE GRANT. IT
WAS. ROVIDE TO MAKE. OUR TRACK.
SURE THERE. IN THE- MAKE SURE
THE FERRY AS WELL SO AS GIVING
AWAY DRIVER'S AND SO AB ONE
LAST QUESTION I REALLY PURSUE
YOU I KNOW YOU'RE JUST BEEN ON
THE JOB FOR A SHORT TIME AND
THAT TO YOU KNOW OUT OF THE HIS
THE- YOUR- YOUR HISTORY. IT IS.
IT AT LEGISLATOR THAT WE SHOULD
BE. CONSCIOUS OF IN THAT YOU
KNOW IT DETECTS A TIME TO WORK
THROUGH THESE PROCESSES AYE. I
WAS I FOUND I WAS AWARE IN
MINTAK I'M DOING SOME
LEGISLATION IN THIS AREA. THAT
THE D. B. WAS SELLING
INFORMATION AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT NEED THAT
INFORMATION SUCH AS ATTORNEYS-
OR- PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS OR-
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES BUT-
THEY'RE ALSO WHOLESALING OR
INFORMATION OUT TO PEOPLE WHO
SELL INFORMATION. NOT SO THE IT
WOULD AT. USING A PROFIT OFF OF
ABOUT FIFTY DOLLARS OR SO CAN
YOU TELL ME WHERE THAT MONEY.
UP SURE I THINK FIFTY DOESN'T
START THE PROGRAM ITSELF TO THE
PROGRAM'S ARCHER DEFINED AS IS
PUBLIC SAFETY THEY CAME THROUGH
LEGISLATION. LIKE THIS TO FIND
THESE WHAT FOR PA SAFETY. WHAT
INFORMATION SHOULD BE PROVIDED
TO INSURANCE COMPANIES. SHE DID
COMMERCIAL CARRIERS ON TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR DRIVERS ARE
SAFE ME FOR THAT THEY HAVE A
VEHICLE. INFRACTIONS THAT
THEY'RE NOTIFIED OF THIS.
THAT'S THAT'S THE PRIMARY THEY
CALL THIS THE PROGRAM LIKE FOR
COMMERCIAL AS A POOL NOTICE
YEAH I ACTUALLY. TRUCKER AND OF
THE I MEAN THE POLOS PROGRAM
BUT- THAT THAT'S INFORMATION
THAT ARE. HARD TO GIVE THE
REQUIRED TO REACH TO RECEIVE.
TAKE IT I'M TALKING. PEOPLE
WERE ABLE. INFORMATION IN IS
THAT ARE PEOPLE WHO SELL AND
FOR ARE A TO BUY I THROUGH THE
PRO THROUGH THE DIEM ACCORDING
THE INFORMATION I HAVE THAT'S
WHAT I WANTED THAT'S WHAT I'M
CONCERNED BUT I'M NOT CONCERN
ABOUT THAT THE NOTICED THAT
THAT LAW AT. OUR OFFICE. IN YOU
ARE COME DROP. GET A D. Y. THAT
YOUR EMPLOYER KNOWS YOU GOTTA
DO YOU AYE THAT'S GREAT
INFORMATION SHOULD BE DONE OR
IF YOUR- INSURANCE BROKER AND
YOU NEED THAT INFORMATION THAT
YOU CAN PERCENT SINCE IT IS
YOUR BUT I'M TALKING ABOUT- BY
INFORMATION IT PERMISSION I
HAVE THE BILL. AT THE ME TO BUY
THAT INFORMATION OR NOT PAUL
NOTICED NOT. SURE IT'S KIND ME
THERE OUGHT OF THE INVEST. YEAH
SO WHICH WE SHOULD COMPARE
NOTES I THINK THAT THE PEOPLE
THAT I'M AWARE FOR THEIR IN
THIS PROGRAM ARE PURCHASED.
CROSS PUBLIC SAFETY THEY'RE NOT
OUT THERE JUST RANDOMLY WE
DON'T SELL INFORMATION TO THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE IT THAT
THAT. NOW WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
BACK TO NINETEEN THE PROGRAM IS
TO THEIR- GOVERNMENT AND ITS
POTENTIAL JUST. THIS THE GOOD
FOR. WHAT IT COSTS TO ACTUALLY.
THE PROGRAM TO THAT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THERE'S NO.
PROFIT THE DMV DOES MAKE A
PROFIT. THAT ACOSTA. GOOD
MINISTER THE- WHICH IS AGAIN IN
THE LEGISLATION AND WE'RE
HEARING TO THAT SO AGAIN IF YOU
HAVE A PARTICULAR CASE I AM
HAPPY TO TALK TO OFFLINE. AT
YOUR CONVENIENCE LOVE TO SEE
YOU KNOW WHATEVER IT MAY BE OUT
THERE THERE'S SOMETHING
SOMETHING WE SHOULD CARE IT.
THAT'S THANK YOU. WELCOME THANK
MISTER CHAIR OF DRUG TO GORDON
THANKS FOR BEING HERE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ONE IS- IN LIGHT OF
THE ANTICIPATED SURGE HAVE YOU
DONE ANALYSIS AS TO- WHAT
EFFICIENCIES WOULD BE. ACHIEVED
IF WE OPENED MORE OFFICES ON
SATURDAY OR LATER HOURS AND
WHERE WE WOULD DO THAT THAT
THAT KIND AND THEN HOW MUCH IT
WOULD COST. REALIZE NOT BEEN.
READ WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT. TO
DO WITH WITH OUR TREASURE HERE
AT HOW WE CAN IMPROVE LAWS
CALIFORNIANS AND SO THAT'S THE
FIRST QUESTIONS HAVE YOU DONE
THAT ANALYSIS. WE'VE THE CLIENT
WHICH SPEAKS TO THE ENTER I
GAVE EARLIER MAKING SURE THAT
WE REDUCE THE CYCLE TIME. TO
TEN THAT I MEANT. EXISTING
EMPLOYEES CONNECTION SERVE MORE
CLIENTS IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW WE-
EMPLOYERS. MAIS THE WIND HAVE
YOU LAST ON THE LIST IS FORGET
OKAY IF WE CAN'T. FISH AND
EFFECTIVE BE UP. CAN'T REDUCE
THE CYCLE TOMMY THE EXISTING-
TRANSACTIONS WHICH WE THINK WE
STOCKTON HEADROOM WE STILL HAVE
SOME ABILITY TO SHRINK THAT
TIME YEAH THEN THE LAST STEP IS
NOW DO WE WANT TO ADD MORE MORE
YES WE ARE ACTUALLY ACTIVELY AT
A WEDDING WHERE WE GO. AS WE
WOULD BE IF AND- WE HAVE AN
EIGHT AND A FINANCIAL ANALYSIS.
THE WITH THAT WE BELIEVE WE
HAVE EXISTING CAPACITY OUR
SATTAR ARE SIX. HOURS BETWEEN
THE OTHER TECH A HUNDRED AND-
OP IS OUR STANDARD OR SATURDAY.
AND OUR JOB NOW IS TO. DRIVE
PEOPLE INTO THOSE OFFICE THEY
REPRESENT URBAN KOREAN
CONCENTRATIONS OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE WITH A- FOR RELATED
DEMAND SO. SO WE HAVE WE DONE
THE INITIAL ANALYSIS A WHAT WE
DO NEXT IN SOME OF THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE EXT ENGINEERING
CORP. OPTIONS OUT. YOU'D
ANALYSIS BIG. IT SOME WE'RE
GOING TO ADD FOR THAT WE'RE
GONNA ASK WHAT IT'S GOING TO
COST TO KEEP MORE OFFICES OPEN
ON SATURDAY WHAT IT'S GONNA
COST TO KEEP MORE OFFICE IS.
OPEN LATE JUST IN CASE WE
CAN'T. OF MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S DRIVERS- SO IF YOU
WOULD DO THAT YES OR- BUT THE
TEARS. WHAT WHAT WHAT THAT
WOULD COST US IS. SINCE YOU'VE
BEEN IF YOU TRIED TO CALL THE
DMV AND GET AN APPOINTMENT JUST
AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN- NO I HAVE.
OKAY I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
DO SO. SO THAT YOU CAN
EXPERIENCE WHAT THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCES WHEN
THEY CALL THE DMV BECAUSE I
MEAN IF I CAN CHANGE YOUR
QUESTION JUST SLIGHTLY HAVE
EVER CALL THE DMV ABSOLUTELY I
CRIED. ACROSS ALL OF OUR- I
UNDERSTAND WAIT TIMES ARE LIKE
A CALL BACK FEATURE TO HELP
PEOPLE IT'S STILL ON. AND THE
SKILLS THAT TALKING ABOUT THE
STAFF. IN THE FEEL OF THE USE
THAT SAME SCHEDULING
METHODOLOGY THERE'S A THERE'S A
TECHNICAL THERE'S A SCIENTIST
FROM THE YOU KNOW THE EARLY
NIGHT AND CALLED LAYING RIGHT.
IN PERSON DATA MATH MODEL TO
MAKE SURE WE HOW TO SET UP. AND
MET OUR- THAT TO THE ARRIVAL
PATTERSON ALL THE LIGHT CALLS
RIGHT STARTING TO. THAT
SOLUTION NOW SO WE CAN ACTUALLY
BETTER MATTER STAFF TO THE
RIVAL PATTERN WE THINK THAT'S-
DRIVE DOWN THE WHOLE TIMES. THE
SAME TIME FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE CALLING WHERE SHE-
CONTINUING INVESTED ABOUT WHAT
IT WHAT CAPABILITY IS AVAILABLE
ONLINE TO WANNA MAKE SURE. IF
YOU'RE CALLING A NEED TO TALK
TO SOMEBODY. YOU KNOW THAT IN
FACT THAT'S THE VIBE THAT
THAT'S THE BIBLE JENNIFER YOU
WHAT WE FOUND FROM MY- AGE IN
MICE MY TO THE DMV. WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT. THE WEB.
WE ALL. READY THERE. THE TEAM
IS THAT. JOB WELL WITH WITH
LEADERSHIP OF OUR PRESENCE TO
MAKE SURE THE WE ACTUALLY DRAW.
THOSE INITIATIVE SO THAT WE CAN.
NEAR A HIGH PERCENT THE THING.
THAT THE FEE OFFICE. ON A YOU
CAN BE ABLE TO SOLVE ON. IN
MEANS OF TRANSACTIONS. I'VE
ASKED YOUR PREDECESSORS THE
SAME QUESTION SO OUT NEXT TIME
WE MEET I'LL ASK YOU THAT SAME
QUESTION IS IT HAVE YOU. AS A-
TUMOR CALLED THE D. B. TO STILL
EXPERIENCE WHAT THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCES WENT IN
THE- DIEM. IT THE IN ADDITION.
A LEAD THAT IS THE GOAL LINE
AND TRY TO TRY TO BASICALLY
MAKE AN APPOINTMENT ONLINE JUST
SO YOU YOU CAN SEE WHAT THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN PERRANCE IS
THEY CALL THE MV YES AS I
MENTIONED IDEAS ARE WEBSITE. IT
IS OUR CALL CENTER VISITED
FORTY DIFFERENT OUGHT AYE AYE
BUT I KNOW I CALL I GET ALL
THAT I DO DO YOU YOU YOU'RE NOT
ALONE. THE FARM DIRECTORS CALL
AGAINST. SO FAR. THE I GUESS
I'M- I. DON'T DIFFERENT CAME UP
WITH OUR- PROFESSIONAL KIND AND
CALLING ON A- HOW. THE EXPIRY.
BUT I THINK IT'S- THANK YOU
PROFESSOR. THEIR WORK HOURS SO
LET'S PLAY THE NUMBERS GAME WE
ACCORDING TO OUR INFORMATION
THE SCRIPT AND THEY WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT POINT SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT STILL NEED TO
GET AN ID AND OR OR ID BASED
SIX POINT GET A 75% OF THE
FEDERAL NUMBER DO WE AGREE WITH
THAT. DO YOU AGREE TO PROVIDE
BACK IN THE I'M NOT. OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION PER MONTH IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE THAT OVER THE
NEXT SEVEN MONTHS MORE OR LESS
RIGHT IF PROCESSING ONE POINT
TWO BILLION FOR THE NEXT SEVEN
MONTHS OCTOBER FRST AB IN YEP
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE DOUBLE
MONTHLY. RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT
FOUR FIFTY THOUSAND SO THE
FIRST QUESTION IS THAT THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET HAS NINE AND A
HALF MILLION FOR PUBLIC
OUTREACH- IN BUT IT'S DOESN'T
SEEM DAY RISEN THAT NUMBER WE
HAVE WEIRD BUT OTHER PUBLIC
OUTREACH. IS YEAH IS THERE
RIGHT YOU HAVE ANY IS THERE ANY
CHANGE OF OPTIMIZING THAT OUT
REACH PLAN OR THE FOR GETTING
PEOPLE TO DMV EXPRESS FOR- WHAT
SOMEONE MORE IS WHAT'S MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY YEAH I KNOW IT'S
A IT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO WE
ACTUALLY UP TO LATELY YEAR ON
THE NOVEMBER TIME FRAME WE WERE
WORKING. IN THE INFORMED BY TO.
YES HELP YOU WILL WARNED ABOUT
REALIZE. BUT THAT WASN'T IT WAS
DRY GOOD OF THE SITE BUT IT
WASN'T SORT OF THE ã DA OF
RELY THESE WE PIVOTED FROM IN
FOR. TO FILL OUT NOW AND OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE TALKED ABOUT
WHAT ME THAT MESSAGING TO
EXPRESS FIRST FIVE REASON MOVED
ASIDE SO AS YOU PAY FOR AT
BECAUSE OF THIS THE ANYA JUST
ON THE RADIO SEE BILL COUNTY
ACROSS IT AND ALSO A MULTIPLE
LÏNG. CULTURE CONSIDER. AS
WELL. WE NEED TO THE MESSAGE TO
YOUR REPLY AND- TO. WE'RE GONNA
TO THAT NOW OF COURSE THE- TO.
THE ESSENTIALLY FOR ANYWHERE
COULD STARTED ON. IF THE APP.
PROCESS AS WAS MENTIONED ARE
OUT MISTER MILLER FROM. BURBANK
AND BUT WHAT DO WE DO THAT DO
I'M- SALUTE TO WE ARE IN THE-
OF A TRY. DO EXACTLY WHAT
ESSENTIALLY CAN ACTUALLY THE-
WITH THE MOBILE SO IS STAR WITH.
UP THE PROCESS EVERY. THE DMV
OFFICE FURNITURE BACK. WE ARE
YOU THE ADVERTISING. STARTED
AWARENESS DRIVE TOWARD ACTS
STAR MESS NOW IS ALL ACTION
BASED. OF NEVER BEEN SHORTER.
IT IN I'LL WORK IN YOU NEED
GOOD UP TAKE. PEOPLE ARE AT OUR
WEBSITE WE'RE STARTING. CHANGE.
BUT THE LANDING POINT EVERYBODY.
R. L. WE WILL PLAN THEIR ONE
YEAH BUT THEN DAY THE CARROT
THAT I MENTIONED. WHICH IS. IT
YOU DO THIS. YOU GET THE
REWARDED REWARD YOU GET A
INSTANT. WE THINK THE CA OF
THOSE THINGS. WILL BE A TO DRY.
ADDITIONAL DEMAND IS IT GOING
TO DOUBLE OUR OUR DEMAND. I
DON'T KNOW. BUT WE THINK
THERE'S GOING TO THEIR
SICKENING UP CYCLE THERE'S A
NUMBER OF CAL ARE. STARTING
PRICE HUNDRED. ALMOST THIS
MONTH THAT. USERS WE NEED TO
HAVE A BETTER CAN. RATE OF
THOSE USERS TO BE TO START THE-
AND WE ARE GET QUICKER
INCENTIVE THEM TO COME. THE
PROP. OF LET'S PRETEND PEOPLE
OF. THIS ON LIVESTREAM. AND ALL.
IN OUR- TWO. THE BETTER. THE
PROCESS. THOSE ONE TWO BILLION
PEOPLE GIVEN THE MISSION. THAT
YOU HAVE THE- PROCESSING PER
TIME AND ALSO THEN THE BY
CENTER THERE. KEEP IN MIND THAT
ONE MILLION THAT WERE TO ABOUT
IS. ISN'T DOUBLE WHERE WE TODAY
REALLY TALKING ABOUT THE- BE.
THE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY. AND THE
ONE TO BUY ANOTHER FOR HUNDRED
FIFTH THOUSAND. DIED SO THE
ETTRICK AS WELL. ARE THE WE
HAVE SPACE THE DAY WE YOUR-
THREE X. THE APP THE CAPACITY
FOR REAL ID PROP BY REDUCING
THAT CYCLE TIME. I WE HAVE THE-
THAT. BUT I THINK THERE'S WE'RE
GONNA. BE OTHERS AND THE BLUE
ABOUT THE WAIT. YOU'RE GOING.
EXT A LITTLE BIT AS WOULD
EXPECT THEM TO DO BE NOW MY
PEOPLE ARE THE OFFICE. THAT IS
THE INTENT EFFECT. BEGIN WORST.
ABLE DOT HELLO. THE MONTH AND
WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE AS MUCH
TIME OUT OF THE OUT OF THE
EXISTING PROCESS SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY HANDLE A MILLION A
MONTH. SO I THINK THE SHORT
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IS. YES
AND BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA OR
AFTER PRESSURE TEST THEM OUT WE
GOT TO GET. PLAN RIGHT SUE THEN
THE YOU HAVE THESE POP UPS
THAT. YES YOU CAN. POP FROM
SOMEPLACE ELSE WARY YES EVER
AIRPORTS FOR V. ONE. ARE YOU
ABLE. WITH YOUR DNA X. THIS. TO
HAVE THOSE PEOPLE RATHER THAN
GO TO THE- THE- NOT ALL OF.
THEM TO GO TO ONE OF THESE POP
UPS THE GET THE PICTURE IN AND
SHOW THESE DOCUMENTS LIVE TO A-
HUMAN BEING OR IS THAT IS THAT
PART OF YOUR WORK PLAN. OF WE
HAD THE BONANZA HERE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY START. COMING TO
FILLING OUT THE APPLICATIONS.
YEAH SO THE EXISTING. STRATEGY
IS PRIMARILY FOR FURTHER INTO.
WITH I THINK WE HAVE ONE
WITHOUT ONE IN SACRAMENTO BUT
GENERALLY THEIR THEIR COMPANY
SPECIFIC WILL BE INTO IT WILL
BE AT INTEL AND COMPANIES LIKE
THAT- BUT THE PLAN IS ACTUALLY
GO NOW FROM. RIGHT YET AGAIN
PLEASE WRITE BECAUSE THEY CAN
GET EITHER GOT PUT SEVEN OUT OF
FIFTY PEOPLE. IN THREE DAYS IN
A ROW THAT'S TRUE THOUGH I WANT.
ANTI WERE TO GO FROM YOU SELECT.
POP UP AT ADDED ENTRY LEVEL
WE'RE GONNA BE NOW AT A LOCAL
LEVEL WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ESSENTIALLY TWO PEOPLE WITH THE
TABLET. THAT'LL BE ABLE TO
FULLY. EXPECT THAT AND- DONE
IT. AGAIN THAT. ADMINISTERING
THE EXAM. AND THE THINGS THAT
RECORD. DEFICIT. OF THOSE ON
THE ON THE GO AND WERE WERE
POOR THAT RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT
PLACE TODAY. BUT WE EXPECT
AVIDLY ACTUALLY SUMMER SO WE'LL
BE ABLE TO BE TO DO IS. WHAT
YOU'RE NOT ONLY YOU HAVE OFFICE
YOU OF THE POP UPS. YOU HAVE TO
BUILD IT DID. DO AT THE END.
THAT SERVICE REQUIRES A DEEP
REPRESENT TO AUTHENTIC YOU. IS
THERE ANY. WE SHOULD KNOW ABOUT
THIS. ANTICIPATED SEARCH THIS
SUMMER. THAT OUT OF PEOPLE THAT
THE- DEAD. EITHER YOU YOU NEED
SOME ASSISTANCE FROM US AND-
THAT CENTER NUMBER WAS AND TO
MEETING- OR- THAT WE HAVEN'T
DISCUSSED. YET NOT AT THIS TIME
I THINK VIDEO. STRATEGY WE HAVE
IN PLACE TODAY I THINK OUR-
COMPREHENSIVE I THINK. WE WILL
TELL. I THINK OVER THE NEXT.
FORTY FIVE DAYS WE START. RE
LAUNCHING PLEASE. LIMITS WILL
PUT HIM TO HOW AFFECTED THEY
ARE WE BELIEVE THEY'RE GONNA BE
VERY EFFECTIVE GIVEN THE
FEEDBACK WE SEE FROM CUSTOMERS.
AS AS A MENTION RIGHT CAN'T.
FORCE PEOPLE WERE WERE NOT A
MANDATORY STATE PEOPLE DO WHAT
THEY DO AND THEY DO WHEN
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT WE'RE
GONNA TRY TO CREATE INCENTIVES
ADD TO GET PEOPLE TO BEHAVE
LEADER IN THE MAYBE THEY
PROBABLY WILL. BUT IN SOME
CASES YOU KNOW WE DON'T
CONTROL- WE DON'T FOR THE
CONTROL THE CALIFORNIA'S TO GET
THEM INTO THE OFFICE OR MAKE IT
IS WE CAN. WHEN THE- SOME BOOKS
AND- AFTER OCTOBER SECOND OKAY.
AND IS THERE A LINE CAPABLE OF.
HAVE ASSN HAVING A CHECK OFF
WHETHER OR NOT YOU HAVE A REAL
ID OR NOT. AND IF NOT. HAVING.
THE CUSTOMER. REFERRED TO THE
REAL ID WEBSITE. IT'S POSSIBLE
I THINK BUT CENTER DOLLARS
POINT WAS WELL WHAT INFORMATION
DO WE WANT TO SHARE WITH
INDUSTRY WELL LIKE IF YOU HAVE.
SOMEBODY BUYING A TICKET. IN
THE ROOM MAYBE NOT AWARE OF
THAT THEY HAVE TO HAVE A REAL
ID AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN.
CITY BY THREE MONTHS IN
ADVANCE- INTO A ON A VACATION
THEY- GET THEIR TICKETS AND UP
FROM A TRAVEL AGENT OR- FROM UP.
A PREVIOUS SPEAKER REALIZATIONS.
THEY HAVE A CHECK OFFICE SAYS
HEY I GUESS YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
TO GET A REAL IDEA ENOUGH TO
CHECK IS NO I DON'T HAVE ONE.
IF THEY CAN BE A MAGICALLY RE
DIRECTED YEAH DIRECTED TO THE
READ RELY RELY D. DOT DMV DOT
GOV. THAT'S YEAH THAT CA DOT
GOV SO IT COULD AUTOMATICALLY
FROM TO THE TO THE WEBSITE
SAYING HEY YOU GOT IT YOU GOT
TO FILL UP START DOING THIS
RIGHT NOW. AND COULD BE THAT
COULD BE A COORDINATION ISSUE
WITH THEIR- TRAVEL INDUSTRY
YEAH WE REACHED OUT TO ALL THE
ALL THE MAJOR AIRLINES OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS. CRY DO AND
UNDERSTAND ONE WITH THEIR
CURRENT PLAN AND TRY TO
ENCOURAGE AND IF THEY DON'T
HAVE PLANS TO GET PLANTS SEEN
SOME AIRLINES THAT HAVE DONE A
VERY GOOD JOB YOU KNOW UNITED
HASN'T REALLY. OF PROMOTE WE-
THE FOOD AND IT WAS NOT A
MENTION AND I LOVE ALASKA I'M
NOT HERE TO BAD MOUTH THE
LATTER BUT IT JUST WASN'T THERE
SO I THINK THEY'RE STILL
OPPORTUNITY. OKAY SO THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN WORK ON WITH
THE INDUSTRY YEAH I THINK WITH
THE WITH THE TRADE GROUPS ARE
HERE I THINK THAT THEY I THINK
THEY ARE WILLING TO DO THAT THE-
DON'T. NUMBER DRESSER. SAY SO
THREE. THE HAS AN ADDRESS. YOUR
THAT IS FLYING OVERSEAS TO. A
LOCATION TO GET- HAVE A
VACATION OR BUSINESS WHATEVER
AND THEN THEY REALIZE THAT.
THEY'RE BOOKING A HOTEL ROOM OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THEY HAVE
TO REALIZE THAT THERE'RE.
TRAVEL PLANS VIA AN AIRLINE HAS
TO BE INVOLVING A REAL ID
BEFORE THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET
THEIR- SO TO AVOID
CANCELLATIONS AND ALL THE
HASSLES. GOOD USE OF THE FIRE
LINE FROM THE HOTEL COULD THEN.
NOTIFY THEM THAT THEY HAVE TO
GO TO THE REAL ID WITH- REAL ID
DOT DMV WEBSITE I AGREE THIS IN
A GENERAL SOMETHING LIKE THAT
YEAH I THINK IF THE IF THE
INDUSTRY ACROSS THE BOARD COULD
BETTER COMMUNICATE THAT YOU
KNOW THIS. WAS A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE. IN OUR THINKING DE
ACTUAL DROP DEAD DATE IS NOT
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH BECAUSE IF
I WALK INTO THE DMV ON
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH. THERE'S NO
WAY ON WALK OUT WITH THAT RELY
DE WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
EFFECTIVE DROP DEAD DATE YEAH I
MEAN JUST JUST TO MAKE THESE
PUT MORE PRESSURE OURSELVES I
REALLY THINK EFFECTIVE DROP
DEAD IN THE DAY WERE. PLAN IS
UP TO THE- THIS ASSUME FOR A
SECOND MAYBE THIS SURGE RAIL AT
THE END OF THE PERIOD THAT
MEANS WERE. A LITTLE BACKLOG
ARE. GEN I NOW WE SAY IT.
BUSINESS TO GET AWAY GOING HIT
THOSE. PEOPLE MOVED. TYPICAL
MONTH SO WE THINK SEPTEMBER
FIRST IS REALLY THE DROP DEAD
DATE FOR PEOPLE ARE GONNA WANT
TO TRAVEL ON OCTOBER FIRST IF
YOU TO TRAVEL AT THANKSGIVING
YOU'RE GONNA TRAVELS OVER THE
NEW YEAR'S OUR CHRISTMAS EVE UP
MORE TIME RIGHT TO THE HE SAID
IN THE INDUSTRY IN THE AIRLINES
WOULD KNOW THAT THAT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE YOUR I. D. OR- THE
COMPLETION PLEADED. MISSION
THEN THAT. EXCEPT MAYBE HAVE A
STAYCATION NOT A VAGUE YOU KNOW
YOU'RE YOUR CALL AND THAT
THAT'S THAT'S A POSSIBILITY
THIS IS SOME SIGNAL THAT THE
TUMOR IS NOT GONNA BE. YOU KNOW
SUPER SURPRISED WELL AID THAT
CANNOT BE FOR PEOPLE TO
ENTERPRISE NOT PEOPLE ARE STILL
CONCERNED. WELL I DIDN'T KNOW I
NEEDED BECAUSE WAS MENTIONED BY
ON THE PANEL RIGHT SO IT'S
STILL TO BE TRANSFERRED TO AND
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
COMMUNICATE. WITH WITH OUR
RESIDENTS- BUT IT CAN BE A
CHALLENGE THANK YOU MISTER
GARDEN OF. WE WOULD LIKE TO US
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IS THERE ARE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME.
ON THE HEARING. AND I SEE NONE.
SO THANK YOU SIR WORK OWSKI AND
WILL ADJOURN THIS MEETING YOU
HAVE ANY CLOSING REMARKS.
PUBLIC SEEMS. THEY'LL NEED
COMMENTING I WILL SEE IF THAT'S
TRUE. THANK YOU WILL.